122.
New Year
welcome to trash taste 2023 that feels
really weird to say yep I know right I
still in my head you know every time
when you would the new year would happen
in the school you'd write the new thing
I'm still in like 2017 in my head
no no it's 23. I'm gonna fix that I'm
still in 2013 dude what I haven't
changed since then honestly I'm kind of
the same you know you know what's like
what do they say about like after you
reach like 23 or something then you
never feel like you've like aged up
anymore yeah after that point it's like
yeah you're probably just like 23 24 I
feel in my head
it's until your body starts like giving
up this is just 30s copium I'm like I'm
still 23 right I'm still young please
say that right they say you're still 20
right 30 right am I right fellow kids
um I I guess I I should start the year
off with a take all right what's your
take Connor all right so my take
um so I was at I was at status and
Emily's house and he asked if I wanted
some anything to drink I was like yeah
sure I'll just I'll have some water so I
pull myself some water he's like what
are you no ice really I said yeah I like
it I like it less when it's cold so on
my tickets that I don't like cold water
I think that I think the room
temperature water is tastier is that
it's easier to drink that's my take for
the year well I've got no trash days 20
20. when we're starting off with a bag
I've been holding this back because we
switched to the two days ago and I
really wanted to be like is this weird
I'm like this is not weird right we're
gonna be like in trash today's 2024 and
we're gonna be like you know what
smiling overrated kind of I kind of like
I just I just had this conversation and
he made me feel like I was weird for
liking water that was from straight from
the [ __ ] tap just just room Ash
temperature I just want to be able to
drink it right then like if it's too
cold my mouth gets too cold and then my
my esophagus feels like it's freezing I
just I just want to have the drink right
away sounds like a skill issue to me
maybe it is easier is there a reason you
just okay yeah since since we're
declaring war against cold Wars
cold water do I hate it when I'm in
America and they give me a cup of water
and it is 99 ice and one drop of water
yeah I hate that okay so like are you
just like a no-wise person no matter
what I'm like a one two Cube guy Max
like I wanted to like lightly cool the
water like I don't want to I don't want
that [ __ ] to be ice cold like lightly
cool I just wanna I want the illusion
that I'm calling it without cooling it
is it possible that I just have a take
that's the same as you because I'm like
no give me all the [ __ ] nice just if
if you're good if you're gonna put this
feels like an AI generated conversation
like a trash taste if you're gonna put
ice cube in it just [ __ ] fill that
[ __ ] up I don't want one or two I want
like a high glass or nothing man and on
brand I'm just in a position where I'm
kind of just like listen listen give me
both bro this is not that I don't both
is fine I'm not like I'm dying on this
hill it's like I just did it and I got I
felt attacked the Titus was like how
dare you yeah I have ice three fat I
don't care that much it's just my
Southeast Asian blood like it's when
when I when I because when we have eyes
is that we need to fill that [ __ ] up to
the brim because the ice melts so
quickly so I I've just got on your
customers
basically right basically okay here's
here's something even more outrageous
that Thailand does not Regis
egregious sorry I I [ __ ] up the words
all the time we have like 900 clubs okay
you talk about putting ice cubes in
water right so here's what they do in
time I know you're gonna tell me now I
know I already hate it they uh serve you
the big I know I know and then they go
with ice with ice in it and they give
you ice and some place and some places
have the ice already in the cup where
you pour the beer and it's why it's
because because of the weather okay
because of the weather yeah because I
want to get to the bottom of this yeah
it's Thai beer made or I guess like
brewed in a way where it's better cold
or is it just like any other beer where
if you put it with some [ __ ] ice
cubes and it's like what the [ __ ] it's
kind of like any other pair honestly
I'm gonna have to be like no that's not
allowed I was gonna give it the benefit
of the doubt if it was like brewed
differently where it's like oh it's
actually better surf chilled but like no
okay but here's the real question would
you what what which of the two evils
would you prefer a warm bear or a beer
with ice in it because you you ain't
getting you ain't getting a cold beer in
Thailand that like maintains itself okay
so you have two options you have two
options either you drink a warm beer or
you drink a beer with ice in it and and
I shoot I like you and I'm gonna be
honest I choose the Ice Cube man I that
to me having a refreshing feeling with a
beer is the Lesser or two evil hold up
would you put ice cubes in a glass of
wine
yeah
because this is the same kind of
question right you're you're
compromising the drink obviously with
stuff like you know whiskey there's
there's arguments there and some people
say the water helps the flavor but with
beer that's flat out just no no no no
you do not the you don't put water to be
fair I've never had warm beard nor beer
with ice probably yeah
but when you're at college or something
right like you just forgot to put in the
fridge you're like all right well I'll
just take a warm beer I mean is that
wall it's like room temp yeah okay room
temp is a bit different to warm well I
mean how warm can it be I mean yeah room
temperature in Thailand it's very
different from room temperature
you have a barbecue in the summer and it
gets you know the beer gets really warm
because you ran out of ice in the cooler
and it's like all right well you know
it's whatever warm beer is fine but
putting water in beer and Ice having
like dilute all of the beer that's water
down beer is a little bit nasty yeah as
if like Coors Light wasn't drinkable
like it wasn't like a [ __ ] what's the
word
um it's hard enough to drink some beers
why the [ __ ] would you want to put water
in it it's it's okay yeah I like I'm not
gonna defend this obviously because I
both are like awful in my mind but like
my Stratton Thailand is like if you if
you have let's say a glass full of ice
for example cools it down very quickly
so it doesn't get like too watered down
so you and since there's like less
volume you can drink it more quickly as
opposed to like letting it get watered
down I choose that evil over having warm
beer because there's just something
about I'm not like a fan of like warm
water in general unless it's kind of
like I'm Ill or something I love warm
water it's like because it reminds me of
tea
a lot more water is like water down tea
I have occasionally just drank in warm
water yeah just like [ __ ] it I just
wanna I want the feeling of tea without
having to make a tea I don't know why
I'm not too sure
it's close enough it's close enough I'm
not sure about that one
I have dog [ __ ] takes all right this is
my dog should take of the Year why don't
they just okay what I don't understand
right is that okay obviously it's hot
outside right yeah and you want to keep
the beer as cold as you possibly can
yeah so why don't they just do that
thing where they do in Japan where they
just shove the the beer like glass yeah
in like a freezer or something so that
it's like chilled out yeah I thought
about it then immediately pull the beer
and then if it starts to get warm just
[ __ ] naked
in Australia we don't have to [ __ ]
worry about it's hot as [ __ ] in
Australia by the glass shredders in the
go-to yeah just use the glass stripe
that's just like a lot of like fridge
space though you know that that's always
storing all those ice cubes I'm
wondering how the like Japan is like so
optimized with space because in most
places like having like a fridge full of
glasses that's just like that's just a
fridge that you're basically like not
using for food or well I guess all right
let's just let's break down the
logistics here okay okay you you let's
say you're cooling the drinks obviously
they stay cooler for longer that's the
benefit yeah uh you probably can't store
all of your drinks in a cooler though
right like you probably don't have a big
enough thing to put all the drinks if
you're a business selling drinks all
over maybe the glass is cool quick
enough where you could just shove them
in because it's you know they fill up
with ice yeah they don't take up that
much room so this maybe you can it can
work I don't know you can stack drinks
right outside like ages I feel like I
don't know this this is like a weird
complex maybe I feel like the bigger
problem is is that if you if you're
giving glasses out to everyone right
like if you give a bottle you sell it
it's done yeah you don't have to worry
about getting it back right if you said
if you give a drink with a glass you
have to get rid of the the glass that
you you know poured the beer out of and
then now you have to try and get the
beer glass back yeah and and also every
that also means everything's so
complicated my head every time you order
a bit every time you order a new beer
you need a new cool glass with it right
I imagine most of it's cans as well
where's those bottles actually no
bottles or glass bottles so there's it's
uh especially if you go to like the
local kind of you know bars and
restaurants they don't really have like
beer on top like single beer isn't good
enough that it like deserves to be on
top I'm gonna say that how loud okay
um it's kind of like it's it's mostly
just in like glass bottles so I mean if
they were why don't they just shove the
glass bottles in the freezer and then
you can just drink straight out of that
the freezer well you know in in a cool
environment so that it's frozen down so
that you can just drink directly rather
than pouring it into a glass just drink
it straight out of the bottle I think
the problem is is that ice cubes are
really [ __ ] easy to make uh yeah but
they also take up space yeah but I think
you can you can make them pretty quickly
and I think maybe keeping glasses in a
fridge will take a while I think that
you can this solution is that making a a
[ __ ] ton of ice cubes is easy yeah and
that keeping glasses cooled and stuff is
complicated it just doesn't seem like
intuitive in any way yeah I agree I mean
I feel like it's probably something
that's just that was that started and
then they just kept doing yeah yeah they
haven't thought I don't know I also I
don't know [ __ ] fridges are expensive
yep come on man what the [ __ ] come on
to me this is just like the equivalent
of being like Oh I'm gonna make some ice
cubes so I'm gonna take some cold water
and then boil it wait till it cools down
and then turn it into ice cubes it's
like kind of it's like two steps in one
when you can just go straight to the one
step
yeah I guess [ __ ] together either way
man I'm not excited for beer in Thailand
that's for sure
I'm gonna be like no Heist please
how do I say no ice sorry how do I say
no ice most places in uh Thailand speak
English so oh okay all right especially
if like you're in Bangkok just be just
yeah just ask for no ice it's pretty
well they give you a weird look if you
say no eyes no I think most tour like
most tourists go through this like
conundrum when I go to Thailand they
like why are they so stupid bro German
would [ __ ] drop dead dude
it'd be like that you know the GIF of
Walter White falling to the ground yeah
when he's like with his mouth open it'd
be there Germans when they go to
Thailand and get offered a beer with ice
[Laughter]
need ice with every glass of water I
think so yeah I think he refuses to
drink like water or is very picky at
least we're gonna get him on we'll get
them on yeah I can grill out more about
this because I I felt like I felt
attacked you know is that an American
thing you think dude yeah they [ __ ]
love it because they love it remember
every single like uh restaurant or Diner
anything you go to you always get the
giant [ __ ] like two liter cup like
plastic cup with a straw
it's not the ice it's not the big ice
cubes either it's like cheese sliced ice
yeah that's that's that I sucks I kind
of like it no no one like the saddest
looking like the saddest looking thing
is with the shaved ice I'm I'm a I'm an
advocate of if it's like the shave like
really small cubes it needs to be up to
like the brim otherwise like when when
you when you have like the uh when you
have a glass and it's just like a little
like one small layer of shaved ice yeah
that just it just looks so sad for me
because I'm like that ice is doing
nothing
I just don't use that ice because I'm
just if I like you know when you because
a lot of the time you go to the soda
machine you do it and it's always that
shitty ice and you're like oh
you know I kind of wanted to like not
have my drink be immediately watered
down so I'm just not gonna put it but I
like crunching on it when you're
finished with them
that's nice
you guys are the monkey brains on this
one I I feel like I'm Giga brain like
I'm like third eyeing this [ __ ] like no
eyes to me please I don't know man how
about tea how do you feel about you the
tea bag like
okay there's like there's like icy and
there's hot tea how do you feel about
lukewarmty just look just like room
temperature tea and you know I mean
obviously it's a lukewarm tea is a tea
that has been left out yeah same with
coffee you know yeah you know it depends
on my mood I'd say 80 of the time I'll
just down it sorry said the time I'll
just count it because I'm like I'm not
excited about it because it's not even
warm anymore like it's kind of room temp
I'm like ah all right all right make
another one that's that's someone who's
addicted to call it's like it's like I
will swallow my pride because I need
this in my voice tea that's right you
know that's what the British people
conquer the world about that's what they
struggle for her identity that's like I
can't throw away what they worked so
hard for and ruined the world for do you
ever like reheat coffee or reheat tea if
it's like going down no no you can't do
that you don't have to do that I'm not
allowed to do that I sometimes do it
sometimes
sometimes just like just like just like
20 seconds in the microwave
that hurts to hear that hurts to hear
it's weird because sometimes I'm okay
with doing that with coffee but I just
refused to with my tea I don't know why
weird mental thing yeah coffee it
doesn't work
coffee doesn't work no tea it works
coffee doesn't I don't like doing it
with tears at the Forbidden technology I
I think it works with coffee fine
I mean I don't let it get to that point
Italians are like Mamma Mia a microwave
and my coffee over here
it's like I don't know
I literally took me five minutes to
process I was like there's no way he
said that that's why it took me so long
what the [ __ ] to be fair 99 times out of
100 I don't let it get to that point I'm
drinking that [ __ ] while it's hot right
but sometimes you get a little bit busy
you know you might you know you might
have to go out for a little bit commit
to the iced coffee you put some [ __ ]
high you put some [ __ ] ice cubes in
it you don't [ __ ] try and turn it
back
it's like it's like climate change we've
gone too far we can't we should just
[ __ ] commit let's just go full
hellscape no I look I look at it I pick
it up and I feel it's lukewarming I'm
like I can fix you let's just shove you
in the microwave
I just realized I was like oh my God I I
did the whole uh I went to America and
back yeah
I was gonna ask about that which was
there how was uh how's the uh Ludwig
chessboxing event good on the scenes
yeah so I went to America for about a
week uh to L.A actually America it's L.A
it's like barely America it's like a
different American yeah we can now say
that now that we've been I I know I've
been to a lot of States guys
I tried all the Local Foods and it's all
the same for the most part
um but yeah no so we went to uh La uh
went for a week uh mainly went out to
watch Chris box which Chris did very
well yeah we're gonna get him on uh
sometimes I'm proud of my boy oh almost
throwing the chess part of the part of
it no no no he he somehow threw more in
the chest than boxing yeah I think uh
like like literally like the throwing of
the punches didn't happen nearly as much
as the throwing of the chest yeah um he
had like was it Checkmate in two and
then he ended up just like giving away
his Queen I was like yeah
how do you do so obviously
in TV yeah
see if you don't know
um yeah uh Chris did chess boxing a lot
of check boxing event we've talked about
a bunch you all probably know but if you
didn't know it was just yeah because
it's boxing someone in between that he
had chess and he'd been training about
this for months and we were all very
excited for it and I said to Ludwig and
Chris was like Hey if you if I get front
row tickets I'll go out because then in
my mind I was like all right well I'll
figure out I'll find some other work
stuff to do to make it worthwhile yeah
uh and luckily I did uh but yeah so I
did that I did uh the thanks mess as
well Jackson yeah that was so much fun
that was crazy had to go after Jack
Black which is nerve-wracking I'm I'm
I've I kept keep saying this I'm like it
is nerve-wracking to see Jack Black kill
it and then you're like all right next
up we got who Sea Dog Connor I guess
this guy yeah it's like kind of crazy I
just seeing him real like he was like
what the [ __ ] oh you're a real person
he's so chill as well of course of
course he is it's like it's like finding
out Keanu Reeves is a nice guy yeah it's
like all right no one no one is
surprised that Jack Black is super chill
and nice yeah he was just like dude
everyone in the studio was like doing
their job but you could tell everyone
was trying to like get closer to watch
yeah it was really cool because it was
it was funny enough it was where we did
our rehearsals for the trash taste tour
was it oh really it was in the exact
same obviously you guys would know this
we did rehearsals before we did our
trash taste tour and the the exact
building that we did it was the same
place as well as oh nice um which was
crazy ah that was cool so I got to see a
bunch of the tour staff that we did with
so that was nice oh [ __ ] yeah so that
was really cool again oh did that and
that was a lot of fun Jack's great we
had Jack on the Pod he's just he's so
funny he's so chill good to hang out
with him and that was great uh see Aaron
again nice so that was so much fun did
that that was crazy like a big family
this past year yeah it was awesome it
was like the highlights like seeing
everyone like the final anime yeah it
was like it felt like when I said bye
the anime ending was about to play like
that's uh so that was fun
um and then uh yeah I stayed at Ludwig's
house as well that was good uh although
there's so many noises his cats and dogs
kept moving around and I'm not used to
sleeping with them right so they would
keep like trying to scratch on the door
or come in and it was it was really
sweet it was nice it was nice yeah I I
his cat is so goddamn cute have you seen
Coots yeah yeah the tiny white one right
yeah like every time I see a pet I'm
like I'm like that's so cute but also
[ __ ] you because I want to piss yeah so
goddamn bad here man I I couldn't help
myself but anyway it was uh Chris came
to LA and I was really excited to see
what Chris thought about La yeah and it
was pretty much what I thought I let
Chris come and tell his thoughts about
La I'm sure he'll go off on one what was
it like behind the scenes of the chess
boxing event yeah so it was uh it was
interesting because obviously I was um I
was staying at Ludwig's house a lot of
the time I was kind of getting just I
was just tagging along to a lot of stuff
whilst I was going to do other stuff and
so
um it seemed like it was kind of all
working nicely and then Ludwig had to
just go from A to B and whatever and so
I was kind of just like hi yeah I'm here
I'll turn up
um and it didn't really start to get
crazy until the weigh-in yeah and that
was that was kind of intense because you
just turn up to this giant 5 000 person
stadium and there's just insane amounts
of stuff and you're like God damn like
this is all being coordinated by well a
streamer essentially like his team his
team's amazing
um
but it was it was just absurd seeing all
that equipment all that gear and it
really felt like oh [ __ ] like I'm I'm
like kind of watching like a like a
serious kind of broadcast almost like
this is I can't imagine it would look
that different
um and the weigh-in was fun
um and oh before that as well I had the
interviews where they I don't know you
saw the videos yeah so they had two
hotel rooms adjacent to each other and
they were both really [ __ ] tiny so
they did the interviews in the hallway
of a hotel room and I was sitting in the
room next door just talking to like
Ludwig or whoever was there just
chatting away while they were getting
interviewed and then they would
constantly go like can you guys shut up
in there we can hear you really easily
so they did the interviews I saw Chris
uh said hi to him like all right you
excited yeah the weigh-in everyone kind
of uh was you could tell that a lot of
the fighters were like not really
prepared to do like the whole I don't
know how to look serious or scary yeah
so kind of like oh
but it was really interesting uh some of
them you could tell they were like yeah
I'm gonna put on a show I'm gonna do it
but yeah dude the the ad was so kind of
like it was like kind of faux tense like
everyone was kind of like we're all
friends right we're gonna punch you the
next time yeah yeah and uh it was just
kind of interesting seeing everyone kind
of like slowly interact with their
groups and kind of not talk and then
some people were like not talking to
other people because they were gonna
fight them and like uh I distinctly
remember that
Chris said hi to his opponent yeah and
uh Chris's coach is insane uh if you
haven't seen any Clips he's like is
there's a video of him basically beating
up a seven foot Korean man and he's like
five ten right and he beats him in
kickboxing like a giant seven foot man
right um it's an insane clip I'm Sean
can play a clip right now it's it's
[ __ ] insane this man's a machine yeah
and he's like full-on like proper
fighter kind of mindset and Chris is
Chris right so uh Chris is talking to
his opponent and then
I'm just standing there watching this
and Nick goes up to Chris he's like all
right Chris now that was the fight no
talking to him now you've got to focus
you're gonna punch that guy don't be
friendly with him
you can see Christian like oh it was
just weird seeing him like go like he's
like you're gonna kill him you can't
talk to him
um but that was the first time we got to
see like Chris's uh opponent really show
up yeah because the point was scary oh
he was pretty
he's a big guy so he wasn't he isn't
like very well trained in boxing he's
done a lot of other martial arts and you
can tell the guy's just been generally
fit yeah his whole life because you look
at a guy like that's the man that's
that's the body of a man who has been
exercising for a long time
it's the same you can see like the
twitch chat as a I wish I could have
seen the twitch chat I was like I was
like dying laughing so he's not seeing
like a switcher because like you know
Chris has Chris has a lot of fans
everyone's cheering for Chris yeah and
his opponent comes on and everything
right it was just like it was just like
a collectively your rip
oh [ __ ] well can you see this man's
packs and this man's back muscles you're
like oh [ __ ] and then you realize you're
like oh okay like when you when you see
them both we saw them both like stand up
you're like oh so Chris had been
training six months just to get like
halfway to where this guy was before he
even started yeah it's like that's that
we're about to witness some murder right
so that's where it was like kind of it's
having a lot of natural Fitness helps so
much Chris was and Chris was just trying
to get rid of his like excess weight
yeah and the way it was like oh this guy
beats Christian length uh an arm arm uh
wingspan uh in height in weight uh Chris
only beats him in age
so maybe that has something I don't know
um and so obviously uh you know Chris
Chris didn't really seem that nervous
though Chris seemed pretty confident
about it I think Chris felt like he had
maybe because uh he'd seen the clip of
his opponent getting knocked out like a
week earlier right right his opponent
got knocked out in one punch a week
earlier right
um and I'm sure Madonna could play a bit
of that
um so you know I think it was like a bit
worried but also everyone's kind of like
well you know maybe maybe Chris can do
well yeah how is he in the dressing room
beforehand
just kind of Chris just sitting there I
think he was trying to just focus he
wasn't really like talking much he was
just kind of like doing it and then I I
went off to go and go to my seat and
watch what were you doing the thing that
Chris does when he's concentrating where
he does the mouth thing
you said that
I said in a video so so um yeah the day
of
um so I I knew obviously all the stuff
that was going to happen I knew that the
table was going to come from the sky and
I knew that uh Ludwig was gonna slap uh
have a slap match with xqc at the end
right so the day off it's like 10 A.M
and um like months months prior to this
I told Ludwig I was like hey if you ever
need anything you want me to get slapped
or whatever I'll do it back up so that
morning of the Box saying it's like it's
like 9am we're going over to go and pick
up xqc and uh yeah he's just not there
just straight up not into this house
geez all right fine I'll just I'll just
call doesn't pick up his phone and I'm
like is that normal he's like yeah
that's normal that's normal I'm like wow
okay so so then we just drive to the
venue and just kind of he's like yeah
I'm sure I'm sure he'll uh I'm sure
he'll respond because you know he's
going on at like 7 P.M yeah so he's got
from like 10 till 7 P.M to like all day
yeah all day uh and so we get to the
venue
I get there very early just kind of
because I'm there from like 11 the event
doesn't start till four so I'm just
looking around just doing stuff getting
lunch talking to people
um and then yeah around 3 P.M is when it
kind of starts to get like all right
okay a bit nervous yeah everyone starts
to get a little bit more tense because
everyone realize all right they're gonna
have to actually like go on and put on a
fight and you know Chris was just
getting ready Nick was doing up his like
uh the things that go on your arm yeah
what are they called and then I'm like
all right Chris I'm gonna go get to my
seat good luck and I'll I'll come meet
you before we uh do the walk-in
and uh so I'm sitting I got like front
row tickets it's [ __ ] awesome the
boxing's great you can see everything I
can't see any of the chests though I
can't see it from where I'm sitting and
the screen is like up here right
directly up and every time uh they went
to play chess initially it was broken
like the board was yeah yeah right as
you saw on the live stream so it was
kind of like oh all right so I guess
we'll just kind of we're kind of like
just quiet for like two minutes in the
boxing side we're like yeah it's so good
front row tickets are amazing for boxing
because you you see and hear all the
punches really clearly and dude you can
see their face when they're like
struggling as well it's it's it's a
pretty [ __ ] fun experience as I say
for my sadistic standpoint
so fun look at these look at these
peasants yeah I know exactly exactly and
like the smashboxing was pretty fun I
think it all went pretty well yeah yeah
um and then yeah uh I went to go and do
the walking thing for Chris uh I I
basically uh I told Chris before I was
like yeah you should um you should do
something when you go out you should do
like some funny a funny bit or something
he was like what why I was like well
because you know it's like a show like
put on a show why not you know because
uh it'll be clipped everywhere there'll
be a lot of people watching and he's
like oh okay so he comes back a day
later he's like I've got an idea we're
gonna throw candy into the crowd and I
was like why
what reason are we doing this so he was
like oh it's Christmas in it I was like
all right fine it's your walk out let's
do it so we go out we have these candy
buckets and I'm just trying to Hype him
up and hype the crowd up right and
whatever we walk out and that was really
fun and I just immediately go to my seat
and I'm watching him and man it was
intense it was it was intense watching
Chris I'm sure you you guys watching
from Amazon oh yeah I was watching from
home yeah yeah it was um the boxing
started and it looked like Chris was not
doing great so I think it was like oh oh
no oh no and then the chess happened
then Chris started winning and we're
like oh my God yes Chris is crushing it
which is literally about to win and then
the boxing happened again we're like all
right just Chris just survive and Chris
wasn't really getting in many punches
right because she's kind of like dodging
and just I I it felt like watching like
you know some take on a Dark Souls boss
yeah he was just like dodging like he
was just like frames
literally he was just like how many
iframes can I get out of this I'm
I'm seeing him like trying to win at the
chest yeah and there's definitely like
it seemed like a he's way more
experienced at least in some form of
Combat Sports right yeah you can tell
because he's constantly going in he
knows his reach and he's playing with it
whereas Chris is a bit more defensive
you're kind of just trying to survive
yeah he's spamming the roll buttons uh
and then yeah he threw massively yeah in
chess yeah and it was like oh okay well
I guess he's lost cause he's not going
to beat him in boxing yeah and he's not
going to beat him in chess now but
somehow his opponent was even [ __ ] at
chess so it all worked out and Chris won
in the end but it was intense it was
like 40 minutes long I was like on the
edge of my seat the entire time oh no so
same here like watching that [ __ ] live I
was just like seeing like Chris kind of
like clutch at the end with the chair so
he's almost [ __ ] screaming yeah it
was hype it was hype I think Chris was a
bit disappointed that he didn't do
better in boxing I'm sure again he'll
he'll talk about all this stuff when he
comes on this episode is sponsored by
expressvpn using the internet without
expressvpn it's like putting your
speakerphone on the bus for your public
calls guys you don't know who knows your
private information anymore and that's
where I use expressvpn did you know that
internet service writers know every
single website you visit what and in the
US they can legally sell this
information to ad companies and Tech
Giants who then use your data to Target
you well this sounds too good to be true
how does this all work well expressvn
crates a secure encrypted Talent between
your device and the internet so people
can't peep on your online activity and
it's so easy to use as well you just
fire up the app and click one button it
works on phones laptops and even routers
so everyone who shares your Wi-Fi can
also be protected no wonder it's rated
number one by Business Insider and the
verb guys you've sold me I'm gonna go to
expressvpn.com trash taste get an extra
three months for free or maybe I'll just
click the link in the description thus
expressvpn.com trash taste back to the
episode congratulations on getting like
a big W not throwing Yourself by the way
so yeah so um during the Andrea fight so
about the third to last fight yeah
um Ladue comes out to me he's like yeah
so uh X hasn't lied to me at all and
it's like it's like five something p.m
yeah and I'm like oh okay
um all right well I guess yeah I'm down
let's do it and she was like all right
all right cool I was like by the way
please don't try and slap me too hard uh
I I have a blood thing so just don't try
and kill me yeah and so he was like oh
okay uh just slap me as hard as you want
uh and I'll reciprocate and I was like
okay cool cool that works that works
nicely
um and then I'm sitting there and I'm
realizing I'm like wait how the [ __ ] am
I going up like how is any of this
working like I don't understand how any
of this is gonna happen like I'm sitting
here like the tech guys don't know I'm
going up so like there's no way like
there's no Graphics or anything like
yeah I'm just sitting there thinking
like what the [ __ ] how does this gonna
work like what do I do what do I like
what do I even like do I do a bit do I
what do I do again it's two hours and
I've been drinking a bunch of beers
before this was free yeah and I was like
[ __ ] yeah I wanna I wanna drink beer and
watch Boxing and so I was like oh [ __ ] I
guess I should stop drinking beer so I
stopped drinking the beer but then I
found that later on after the fight the
Ludwig started drinking shots before
because he wanted to get ready for it I
was like [ __ ] I should have kept
drinking so like 30 minutes before I'm
about to go up because because the
fights could either be five minutes or
30 right yeah so I was like [ __ ]
myself I'm like [ __ ] I don't know like
when I'm going up because the toast
versus Point grow match started and it
looked like Tosh was about to lose
immediately and so I was like [ __ ] I'm
about to go out so I still get really
[ __ ] nervous and uh one of logic's
Team comes to me and I'm like I'm like
uh yeah so like what how is this working
like what the [ __ ] do I do and they were
like uh well we'll figure it out in a
sec so the fight ends
before the fight ends Lotto comes over
and he's like okay this is what we're
gonna do we're gonna we're gonna throw
it to you and you're gonna come in and
do whatever you want do whatever I want
what do you mean like I'm like give me a
roll do I beat am I the bad guy the good
guy
oh and he was like oh just whatever
feels right I'm like oh my God okay fine
so then yeah I'm sitting there and then
watching it and I didn't know when they
were gonna queue right so I'm just kind
of like all right waiting waiting and
they go is there anyone in the audience
who wants to slap Ludwig and I'm like oh
[ __ ] I guess I'll put my hand up there's
this great shot yeah I'll just you just
like casually like yeah yes my time
finally my time has come so yeah I
thought to myself I was like I want to
make it look as like Suave and Casual as
possible so that when I go up it looks
really like [ __ ] extra and over the
top so I'm just sat there like yeah okay
I guess I was laughing because I can and
then yeah it really surreal Herring
[ __ ] German girl was that Sea Dog Jim
is so [ __ ] cool man Jim is such a
nice guy seems like such a cool dude and
uh yeah then going up and I was like all
right whatever it's just all autopilot
I'll just figure it out we'll just do it
and uh I hope I did a good job I don't
know maybe the audience uh I saw a lot
of nice comments so I'm hoping that I
did it went really well yeah and it was
a good match uh we slapped each other
everyone everyone kept saying that we
were faking our slaps we were too Fair
the last two slabs were pretty hard the
first two were like yeah they were they
were holding back yeah so we also didn't
I was at the mindset of like I'm not
actually trying to injure him I don't
actually want to hurt him like I just
want to make it look hard yeah without
actually injuring him yeah I did give
him a little bit of a bruise on the last
lap that I've gotten pretty good with uh
he did ask me to go a lot harder so I
did but I still didn't do like fully 100
but also I don't know I feel like that
you don't need that that's a bit
excessive feeling is that really gonna
add to anything if I give him a
concussion
I don't think it needed to happen but I
think it all worked out and I I got my
belt I didn't choke uh I think uh it was
it was uh you know he definitely wanted
to get the time the clock closer yeah um
at some point so you wanted to get it
like I think very close he's a master at
stalling for Content yeah um but I think
he accidentally
I think he actually tried to win yeah he
might he might say he threw for Conte I
think he actually tried to win because
if you watch back you can see him trying
to press the clock again uh he just
didn't press it in time but then also we
also broke so many rules like I didn't I
totally forgot you're not allowed to
move a chess piece and then press the
clock with the other hand
oh but then also half of these matches
no one [ __ ] played the chess
correctly anyway so some people just
like move to peace and didn't didn't
even yes the clock yeah Chris's opponent
did it a few times yeah
um so I was like yeah got it got my dub
got the uh got the belt oh now I was a
happy boy dude man I I don't know if you
you've had this before but whenever you
have like a massive serotonin rush like
the next day you're like [ __ ] this is
I'm so sad yeah just I was just sad the
next day I was like [ __ ] even though I
was having like a fun time we were just
I was just hanging out with my friends I
was just like damn I'm just sad I think
the serotonin come down was like really
high yeah I get that uh and that was I
was like oh man this sucks and then the
next day we uh flew to San Francisco uh
we did a sushi stream where we did uh
learn sushi with a sushi Master yeah
Chef right a Michelin star Sushi yeah
and uh he was very funny he was great it
was a really fun stream check it out if
you haven't uh we basically just tried
to prepare Sushi and I was not good
I mean we knew you weren't good at
cooking anyway yeah she's hard man I
know it looks easy they're just kind of
like fish there you go dude that's just
hard yeah this man this man was cutting
up cucumbers like it was like like arts
and crafts insane insane yeah it's
almost it's almost like sushi chefs have
to go through years okay to get really
really good at Sushi yeah yeah that's
crazy that's crazy dude this man turned
a cucumber into a Christmas tree
isn't that insane yeah I'm trying to
imagine how yeah yeah I know right
exactly I I didn't know that too until
they showed me did he do it in like the
one Fell Swoop you probably hit him you
probably killed him he was like and then
he did like an accordion with the
Cucumber
I tried I copied exactly what he did and
it just didn't work it just fell apart
he just didn't even do anything and I
was like what the [ __ ] how did he do
that so I copied him yeah it's there's
there's like some magic especially like
with some of the cutting techniques I've
seen where you just see like Chef's Lich
it's literally literally like real life
choker gecko where she's like yeah it's
what he did that's what he did I copied
that it didn't work
so I realized I'm just not meant to be a
chef but then copied that now I have
three listings copy that I just have
half a cucumber and then yeah uh I flew
back we flew to San Francisco flew back
the same day and the next day I flew
back to Japan and uh man yeah it was
literally like one week of just
back-to-back stuff and it was it was
pretty fun I mean I got so much work
done it was great I I like it when I can
do a trip like that where I just go away
for a week it's so much work done come
back and done like I did the stream as
well where I reviewed cereal with Chris
and Ludwig yeah yeah and that was a lot
of fun
um but yeah it was it was just great I
mean getting it's really satisfying
planning out a trip like that and just
again back and then you're like oh nice
all right that was like productive did
you help Chris uh like practice that
Chess at all yeah I'm wondering like how
much he did practice that chess I helped
him practice a tiny bit mainly because
we never really ended up just we just
didn't do it um he knew how to play
beforehand though right yeah he knew how
to play he was okay
um I think
yeah he said he was 800 I don't I think
that's cap
um he wouldn't tell me he's rating
um I I I think he said he was 800
because that's like the default rating I
think so it's like yeah yeah
guys I'm 800.
650 600 maybe
um because he was like I'm gonna do the
queen scan bit
he wanted to do the Queen's Campbell
okay like which is a chess opening uh
and before I was kind of like I was like
well I mean I mean I guess it's fine
like I I told him I was like I would
have just done the classic the E4 yeah
yeah just a [ __ ] moving like it's
easy you're white he was playing white
as well right so I was like you could
just play that but I was like honestly
you've been playing this entire time
with Queen's Gambit me telling you to
swap it now is not going to do you any
favors just do it just don't blunder
your queen and he's like and then he
kept saying it he kept saying the days
leading before as long as I just jump
under the queen I'm happy
that's what he kept saying I kept saying
as long as I don't blunder the queen I
could literally see how tilted he was
after he blundered that for you yeah
there's a there was a thing that wasn't
picked up on the cameras but after he
did that the round like when the thing
ding went and it was next to boxing he
stood up looked at me and did this
and I was I was like this
yeah it was yeah I mean made a more
dramatic run yeah did a full content
you know I I knew that his opponent was
terrible at chess so I was like honestly
don't worry about it just play yeah how
bad could it go and then it nearly went
extremely badly and then he literally
let his opponent promote to a queen but
apparently he didn't even know that was
a thing
so he was one one move away so in chess
if you move the pawn all the way to the
end of the board you can get a queen
yeah and somehow Chris had thrown his
Queen and then allowed him to get his
Pawn One move away from promoting with
nothing defending it and again I think
they both missed that and they both
missed it yeah and he he was one move
away at any point he could just got
another queen and it probably would have
just ended the game
um he just didn't do it yeah and then
later someone had said that apparently
he just didn't know that was a thing oh
my God so Chris Chris is fighting a man
who is like a pro in boxing and a
toddler in chess so luckily it worked
out for him geez yeah it was like a
really really impressive the event was
insane the event was insane yeah it was
it's like considering how many moving
Parts like I have to like go down for
that kind of event to happen and he was
like talking about it for like ages as
well dude just seeing all the staff
there I was like my God this is so
stressful but he has like a he has like
a team of I think 50 employees so you've
got a really good amount of people
working on the stuff and you know he's
not always there like on the floor be
like you do this it's like it's just
like you know he works with his team and
yeah his team's great yeah and they're
so [ __ ] cool all of them are so nice
yeah just like going to seeing like Live
Events like that going to [ __ ] like Moga
money live and also you know tourism I'm
like [ __ ] live live things a lot of
[ __ ] fun you know yeah yeah that's
why I really want to start doing some as
well and do some more fun live stuff
maybe this year hopefully things first
there's just something about having that
audience energy in front of you that
especially after the pandemic I've just
like sorely sorely missed as well yeah I
think after the tour as well it made me
think like damn I really want to figure
out a way to do some live audience stuff
even if that means me going to America
for like a week to do something well
that's serotonin Rush man it's so good
there's something different man it's
just like it's like you know I love
streaming a lot but I love I love the
idea of having these big things you that
you work towards yeah um and um yeah I'm
really excited I really want to do some
stuff uh keep press peeled might be some
stuff coming who knows next year yeah
we'll see we'll see
and it's just great like every time I go
out to LA
um you know I think La is a is an
interesting City this is the nicest way
I could say it it's terrible it's a
terrible it's a terrible City but every
time I go there I always get so inspired
seeing wow like the Creator scene is
over there how like how hard and crazy
people are working out there
um you know obviously there's some
there's some characters that's that you
know it sucks and a lot of people are
not nice did you ever find out where xqc
was uh no I have no idea okay we just
didn't show up okay I think he I think
he replied actually to Ludwig at like
eight or nine PM being like sorry I just
woke up
I think I think I don't know something
like that so that was that man is on his
own time zone yeah yeah it's what it is
man when you're the biggest you can you
can just not turn up to stuff I guess
yeah no one cares
um uh yeah I I just every time I go
there I get so inspired and like seeing
like seeing a lottery just do his thing
man he's such a sober professional and
the stuff that they're doing and pushing
live streaming forward is like oh my God
that's just badass yeah and they're like
how can you see that stuff and not be
like inspired to want to better your own
stuff and push it further yeah it's kind
of like every time I do go to La for
Anime Expo or whatever and like you get
to talk to a lot of these other creators
it does like light a fire on you oh for
sure for sure yeah and then you come
back to Japan you're like like what can
I do here so yeah we can't do anything
yeah which is why I'm like man we should
just make our own we should do it yeah
because like just seeing some of like
the ideas and some of the [ __ ] they can
get away with over there just kind of
like oh I wish I could do this in Japan
as well right yeah yeah because it's
just like the infrastructure is then
it's just a lot
easier just to you know get a be able to
get a camera and just be able to like do
exciting things it's uh you know I have
a lot of problems with um La as as we've
all like mentioned yeah of course uh
we've all had our qualms with it but
it's they they have like all of the
instructor there just to make [ __ ] down
and get you yeah I mean like you know if
you want to hire out three guys and
someone who knows how to live a live
broadcast an audio guy who knows how to
get it all done it's like boom in L.A
that's easy but in Japan it's like
impossible yeah yeah you know there are
Japanese people who do who do it but
it's like they won't be nearly as
flexible enough
to do what we would need them to do and
also they would charge so goddamn much
money where if you know it's it's just
makes more sense at that point just if
you're going to be doing it consistently
just make your own team yeah yeah get
all this stuff like when we did that
Sushi stream that was three RED cameras
they were using to stream three Cinema
cameras to stream that insane for those
of you don't know each one is like 20
grand no no no there's more more than
that more
they're like they're like 30 to 40 I
think but just just the the camera yeah
and then you need to buy all the other
[ __ ] which adds up a lot it's a lot yeah
the SSD is also red yeah you can't use
others they have their own proprietary
stuff which is kind of a that's a whole
link so patrons we know what we want for
Christmas
I did that uh I did a poker stream
recently as well where I got invited to
play poker with a bunch of jazz people
who I just only kind of briefly spoke to
once and I kind of thought yeah this
sounds intimidating just turning up to a
it was a shogi building that they rented
out to play poker cool um uh and it was
just they kind of brokenly messaged me
in English being like poker yes alcohol
yes uh and then as I'm like going over
there yeah they mentioned me being like
poker no I'm like what what do you what
but then I get there and they're like oh
yeah all good all good what the [ __ ]
just message me in Japanese and I'll
Google translate them
I met these people on a stream and one
of them is like a professional poker
player in Japan he travels a lot is that
a thing so so recreational poker is
really big here
um if you want to play you want to pay
in yeah and yeah you can't like win
money necessarily but yeah a lot of
people just like practice here and then
they go to foreign countries to compete
um so a lot of them will go to go across
Europe we'll go across America uh just
playing poker tournaments but they
practice a lot here there's a really big
scene for it here they were telling me
that there was a YouTuber who's in Japan
he's a poker YouTuber with 1 million
subscribers and that's a lot I think I
know yeah he has his own brand of poker
chips
yeah that's one million in Japan is
[ __ ] poke is pretty big in Japan like
you if you look on the map like you go
like Tokyo and type in like poker
there's a lot of Poker places that pop
up right um obviously you can't gamble
any real money it's like all
recreational and you can buy drinks and
stuff and yeah they sometimes they have
like fun tournaments and stuff it's like
it's just for fun and because a lot of
people like playing poker
um and yeah so he was a poker Pro and
they just messaged me being like hey do
you want to come play poker with us
three and five other people you've never
met who don't speak English and I was
like all right [ __ ] it sure let's do it
why not it went really well they were
already chill they were already fun
um and it made me really want to do like
oh man I wish you just I was like man I
should just buy a poker table just cut
out some holes for the cards some put
some plexiglass and then hook up cameras
underneath and then have like three
cameras going around I'm like man we
could we could do this it'd be expensive
but I'm wondering like I'm like damn I
should I should I should do this yeah if
you do hit me up because I [ __ ] I
[ __ ] love it
do the work do the thing I just want to
play here yeah I do I I really want to
do some [ __ ] like that where I'm like
all right we can get a space that is
built for like live stream content where
you can like remake it into some stuff
we'll see we'll see I don't know maybe
I'll be ambitious I don't know I mean
poke is just a lot of fun in general and
then yeah it's easy focus is fun it's
great poker's the fun part you know have
you ever played poker Cherry yeah I play
poker times I played it in uh Hokkaido
actually like uh earlier this year yeah
when I was up there with a few of my
friends
um yeah like there's a yeah as as Conor
was saying there's a ton of places
especially in like the biggest cities as
well like yeah and support there's so
many
um and super fun and again it's like a
whole buy-in thing and then when you
finish with it you get like kind of I
guess like a credit type of thing
um the way you can use it again to buy
yourself back in right if you go back to
that store for example
um but yeah it's like you just play with
a bunch of like random Japanese people
who are just like having drinks and just
like hanging out it's a good
conversation game yeah it is it's a lot
of time to talk perfect perfect like
boys night just because it's like it's
it's the perfect mix between okay we're
playing a game but also enough time to
just like chill out with the boys and
just have a conversation for sure yeah
anything like that I remember like when
we went to Vegas we tried going to like
the poker tables in Vegas and then yeah
we saw the buy-ins there and we're like
there's like a minimum 100 bucks a hand
yeah and so that's a minimum right so
you need least a few thousand even sit
down and then I when we walked past it
we just saw like dude people looked
intense yeah and like people were like
shouting and stuff like that situations
I think it's a lot of those people are
gambling with like their entire life
like War yeah uh and so I was like man I
don't think this is the vibe yeah I
don't think this should be fine yeah I
think I I wanted to have a little fun
poker game with some friends maybe but
no not not uh so we just ended up at the
roulette table right yeah we went to
Vegas on the tour and I we me and God
had never been so we were like wow we
want to see the casinos because like
that's that's all you do in Vegas have a
look so that was it was crazy it was
overwhelming yeah yeah it was insane
Vegas was so much fun though it's a
crazy City it's it it is I mean you've
been plenty of times obviously you're uh
yeah you're definitely I I've never seen
an American city that made it so
apparent that if you want to spend money
you can just like get way better
treatment yeah like we because we were
we were lining up for a cab right
um to go back to our uh hotel and as as
we were lining up this line is long it's
like it's like maybe like a 20 30 minute
wait and uh this guy just shouts like if
you want a private vehicle it's fifty
dollars and I was like oh so we can just
skip the whole line if we pay 50 bucks
like yeah it's been gone like oh [ __ ] it
yeah let's do that
so we just did that we just skipped the
whole line through 50 bucks it's like in
my head I'm like why would everyone here
was like probably wasting so much money
on these tables just say 50 bucks so you
could skip the line there are some
people have like lost a lot of money oh
I know I know I know any more money on
taxis man yeah I'd rather lose money on
a cab ride and tip the guy than give a
casino more money I am I am sad that me
and Connor weren't able to go to like
the Caesar's Palace buffet though that
was that was that was a wonderful you
went to the buffet right yeah yeah we
took them um we did my friend did this
uh who lives in Vegas is also a YouTuber
um we've got digital next uh he uh he
did this I've never seen this ball or
move before but um it was a huge line of
The Season's Palace buffet right it's
like one it's in my opinion one of the
best buffets like ever okay especially
in Vegas so we were like all right we
got a lot of Staff here who have never
been to you know house Buffet we got to
take the Caesar Palace buffet and he was
like yeah the line might be really long
especially since we haven't reserved it
and we show up and sure enough there's
no like you know 50 to 100 people
waiting in Minecraft it's like a two
hour wait I'm just like and we're just
standing around being like all right
[ __ ] what are we gonna do and then my
friend digital was just like all right I
I got this and he walks into the queue
and like calls over just like a stuff
and he goes yeah so uh I've got a bunch
of famous people here with me right now
um and they really want to sit down and
they want to grab a seat where they
can't really be seen because they might
be bombarded by fans and that might be a
problem with that no way did this and
the guy was like
all right give me a second because he
goes back and he like gets on a phone
call for like 10 minutes yeah and he
goes okay so we got a C for you right
now come on through and we just skipped
the whole [ __ ] line and went to the
biggest nicest seat in the back of the
restaurant I was like how the [ __ ] did
you do that even if I was [ __ ] like
Leonardo DiCaprio I wouldn't have the
balls today
absolute confidence in this place like
there's some famous people are just like
that's such a that's such an alpha move
that's like speech 100.
American is a different bro what does
that work I can't let that worked either
what the [ __ ] that must happen quite
often I mean this is Vegas we're talking
about right so there's probably just
[ __ ] celebrities walking around all
the time yeah I mean but it's just like
the fact that it was just like me and
like a bunch of the tour stuff we're
just standing around me like
and the guy looking at us like what's
the face those are the famous people
actually that's the anime man I don't
know if you know yeah I saw a uh claw
machine in one of the casinos really it
was like a gambling claw machine
money oh just like so you you could bet
however much you wanted to and then it
would be like hey if you've got one of
the balls you'd get this much back uh so
I tried it and I was like nah this [ __ ]
ain't gonna now this [ __ ] ain't working
this [ __ ] this [ __ ] is not happening
at most I might get it once but because
it's like a computer that decides how
much money you get obviously the
computer will probably decide that you
get to to win when it's a very tiny
amount right so it's like it's like this
[ __ ] this is so dumb it's not happening
going on tour has made me realize like
just Conor has an unhealthy addiction to
claw machines now I don't know if I if I
see one I kind of have to play it I kind
of I don't know why it's kind of you
think I'd be sick of them but I kind of
just always want to play them the
system's going on man yeah I know right
he's it's like the jumping effect or
like all over again you've like you've
done it so much
you've tortured yourself with claw
machines so much like you've convinced
yourself that you like it yeah I've
spent like God
close to 10 grand yeah I never told you
the story but like the the point I
realized that Connor oh Conor's like
actually addicted addicted was I so we
uh went to one of the uh League world's
like quarterfinals or it was like kind
of the group no it was the group stages
in New York yeah and uh we're going and
of course we're going in to watch League
that's why we're going there
um and so we go to take our seats and
there's just like one single like claw
machine in this entire building right
it's just like one thing that they've
put there and no one's like playing in
it and I just no no no [ __ ] off people
are playing no no one we were walking in
yeah it's free it's free to play it was
free to play and Connor just glances at
it and just goes oh there's a claw
machine and then I was like yeah there's
a global machine I don't know what you
can when did did you did you know what
you could win yeah so it was like it was
like a stress ball I guess of like
League things there was like the like
gragas barrel and a minion oh yeah yeah
so it was just something for like fans
and viewers to do like in between right
so we watched like the first two games
at this uh this event that we're in
um and then Conor's like I'm gonna go to
the toilet I'm like okay sure thing I
did go to the toilet and he did go to
the toilet and so what proceeds to
happen is I
um so I so before the next game starts I
go out as well I had to go to the toilet
before next game starts and I see Connor
on this claw machine with like five
people around him right and I just
thought I just thought oh it's uh
because actually at that League event we
got recognized so much because of course
yeah League fans and weaves we we go
hand in hand so I thought you know
Connor's just like Connor's playing up
you know we had we have a few fans there
he's playing a few cool machines with
some fans go to the toilet come back
watch the match the entire match is like
I watched the entire match by myself
thinking what the [ __ ] did Connor go
where did he go he missed an entire
match of League
it was a [ __ ] game so I
is a group of like 30 people making a
semi-circle around Connor playing this
[ __ ] claw machine he had been playing
this claw machine for 40 minutes
and I was like God have you been here
this entire time and he's like yeah I
haven't won yet I'm not leaving until
I've won like one of these [ __ ] boys
yeah so so I went to the toilet and then
there was no line for it so and I'd seen
a line earlier so I was like oh I'll
just have a go and then I started
getting recognized a lot by people there
and so people started lining up to like
um some people were just waiting to take
photos some people just wanted to watch
me play and then some people the people
would just gather and say like oh I've
heard this guy's good at this people
would just watch and so yeah like gaunt
said by the end of it I had like a group
of 30 people and it it was kind of like
but they were all interacting and we
were like everyone was like talking [ __ ]
everyone was like bantering yeah I kind
of felt like a like Spartacus with my
like audience is like are you not
entertained let's get it and I kept
getting like perfect grips perfect claws
perfect like but every single time I
nailed the grip I was there I had the
perfect Tech every single time and for
40 minutes I didn't win and then just
wasn't meant to be I was asking everyone
like has anybody seen anybody win this
and they were like no no there's like
three machines around the whole menu and
they're like obviously anyone win I'm
like this is [ __ ] we should Riot we
should we should rob it we should just
tip this thing over and take its
contents and so the woman came to fill
over one of the other machines and we
were like why what and then some of the
guys started asking like why can't we
win this this guy's been playing for
like 50 minutes and we can't win they're
like that's easy it's free to play a
bunch of kids have won them we're like
no no one's want anything what are you
talking about the government is lying to
us begin the crew name they literally
watched me for 50 minutes nail it nail
it nail it and I didn't win a single
[ __ ] time a two dollar stress toy uh
so yeah I was just kind of sad about
that and I stand up winning no I didn't
I didn't I gave up just eventually it
was like I gotta actually like because
I'd asked uh somebody I uh a good friend
not a good friend I know somebody I knew
hey can I have tickets please because
the tickets are all sold out so I was
like I should go watch the game so after
after 40 minutes like that's enough
that's enough Jesus I like how you was a
free claw machine I was like and you're
like I want a refund give me a refund
I want to refund on my time that was
[ __ ] up League of Legends uh if you
ever watch this clip please consider
sending me a free uh stress toy uh
because I needed it afterwards that was
unfair
I bought so many white claws at that
venue and they were they were like 15
white clothes oh my God I needed to get
through that claw man I was like I was
so sad I also had a very first Geeks
plus office Christmas party the other
day which was a lot of fun you missed
the beginning of that I did I did yeah I
was so I think I think the highlight of
that like of that night because I've
been thinking about it ever since that
night was uh we had like a secret Santa
right
so we had we had a Secret Santa you know
everyone exactly everyone got some nice
gifts and everyone but I I forgot there
was someone who bought uh what was it
what was that like [ __ ] sorry Kendama
yeah yeah yeah like a kendama like
Japanese toy and
there was a revolution that that like
that like opened my mind to be like I
didn't realize something so simple could
be so much [ __ ] fun holy [ __ ] it was
like I forgot who actually got it for
the for the yeah that's yeah that's
right diet has got it for a present who
gave it to Dougie ah I think Anna did
right oh Anna did yeah Anna gave it to
Davis for it for the present and it was
you know it's just like a small little
Kendama and and Titus was like what is
this and you know someone had to show
him how to do it by the end of the night
there was like at all times at least
seven people just in a semi-circle
surrounding them being like me next give
me next come on I got that I got it I
can nail it don't give it to me [ __ ] I
can do it it got so competitive it's
just it just made me realize damn kids
in the 1950s had it [ __ ] good man
holy [ __ ] who needs a [ __ ] iPad who
needs [ __ ] fortnite when we have like
a [ __ ] Ken though when you get
cracked in it then it's no longer fun
because you can do it every time no
because then you start to learn like the
special tricks and those take like years
to perfect good I'm good honestly I've
been thinking about getting one myself
I'm just a literal children's toy it's
actually so fun you know because like
initially you look you don't know you
haven't tried it I know what it is I've
used it yeah initially you look at it
and you're like this is this is [ __ ]
stupid I mean you try once you're like
I'm trying to go
I'm gonna try it again I'm gonna try it
again and and it's it's got like that
perfect I'm gonna call it like a
gameplay Loop of just like just one more
time one more time I'll get at this
level I'll get this slime Joey is
[ __ ] cracked today because he he Joey
showed us the Strat and I think that's
what made it like so much fun because we
could see what we needed to do so the
stride is just like you have to pull up
you have to pull the string up at like
the perfect amount like strength like
directly vertical like directly vertical
and you need to [ __ ] just like
perfectly land it on the Kendama and so
there are like four stages of difficulty
so they're like there's like uh if you
know his here's what it looks like on
screen right so you got like three
appendages uh and each appendage has
like a uh cup that is a different kind
of size
um and Joey did it like so the smaller
the smaller the size the harder it is to
land it on that cup and Joey like Joey
tried to do it Joey showed us to do it
on like the hardest difficulty setting
and everyone's like that looks easy I'm
just gonna go for the hardest difficulty
setting right off the bat a quality
setting of your kids toy yeah yeah and
uh yeah and then we like I think a group
of like [ __ ] seven of us wasted two
hours just watching this ball go [ __ ]
up and down
it was it was the hypest thing to happen
when anyone got it the first time
everyone was just like oh oh literally
you showed me how to like spin it and oh
yeah
I told people how to do it on like the
spike like to get the hole on the spike
which is the hardest one and I did it
and I did a first go and even I was
surprised I was like oh [ __ ] and then
everyone was like yo let me try that and
for like the next two hours everyone's
just trying to do it what gifted uh you
guys supposed to both give and receive
uh so I didn't find out that we were
doing a secret santa until literally
like two hours before I was supposed to
show up right mailing was like by the
way we're doing a secret sound I wasn't
here for this because I was on a plane
yeah but Conor was on his way back from
the US right so so mailing texted me
like two hours before I was supposed to
show up being like by the way we're
doing a secret santa no pressure though
I was like why are you telling me
because you'll you'll end the loop if
you don't yeah exactly so I was just
like well [ __ ] I don't have time to go
out to shop for something let alone wrap
it up so I just gotta like grab
something from home and so I just was
like all right I guess if any if
everyone's kind of doing like joke gifts
or whatever and like not serious gifts
then I'll just I'll just give a joke
gift so I just grabbed my copy of uh
tf's tsf monogatari by Shin Noel and
just wrap that [ __ ] up yeah and placed
it and then of course out of all of the
people who had to grab my gift there are
about 40 40. yeah those are like 30 or
40 people there yeah I had a one in 30
to 40 chance that Sydney would grab my
gift and she grabbed my gift oh well and
I was like this was it all just like a
free-for-all you just grabbed a gift you
didn't have a person
we had a system I don't know mailings
did it in the most arbitrary system I've
ever seen in my life yeah like we were
we were we had like we used up like 20
to 30 minutes figuring out system don't
you just normally just go online and
type everyone's names in then it tells
you if you're buying a gift for
no no no because it was like it was it
was all around it was all like
randomized yeah that's random though
like you put everyone's name into a
website and it'll be like God is your
Secret Santa oh and they'll get the same
thing
for me it was always just like okay
there's you know all the presents are at
the bottom of the tree right yeah yeah
and then you it's just a free you just
go up and ground no it's more fun to
know who you're buying for and then but
then if it doesn't pick up a secret
santa no it's secret because you don't
know who's buying for you you never know
who's buying for you so this uh well I
don't know if it's different because
this was called like white elephant so I
don't know if the rules are different I
mean the other thing I know is secret
santa white elephant why elephant it's
basically the same thing but you just
it's kind of like more of like you buy a
random gift that you put into the pool
and then yeah like all the gifts are
randomized and you kind of like pick
from you don't know who you're buying
for you don't know and um so we came up
like mailing uh being the mom came up
with this like [ __ ] overly
complicated system where she was like
how many people bought gifts everyone
and put your hands up right now okay
we're all gonna start we're all going to
assign you a random number and
everything like that and so we spend
like 20 minutes trying to figure out the
system and Joey just goes wouldn't it be
what's stopping us from just everyone
taking a random gift and then it's like
no no no we cannot do that we need the
numbers we need the numbers and so I had
so we all had to wait for meleen to like
write like on each individual note
[ __ ] pad just be like write a number
and then like put it in a bag and then
everyone pick it out and then calling
the number like I was like I was at the
[ __ ] Ward office I was just like
waiting for my number
21 I'm just like she's from Japan this
is trying to japanify it I'm just like
oh my God it's like welcome to the DIA
Japan DMV this is exactly so Sydney got
your gift Sydney got my gift and oh and
I was like no all right come on Sydney
replace it with someone because like
that's just that's a lame present for
you right like you probably already have
a copy of that so she gave it to master
instead yeah
um you know he enjoyed it yeah
um and then I got uh I forgot too bored
for me I got sekihang which is like the
the red rice oh you know that so in
Japan there's this thing which is called
sticky hands red rice and traditionally
you cook it like parents cook it for
their daughters when they hit puberty
oh that's nice yeah wait wait wait what
think about that wait why
because they've got their period for the
first time
they eat them red rice they give them
red rice because they hit that period
I'm not joking that is a tradition
that's been going on and someone was
like I'm a bite that's like that's like
me taking my first [ __ ] and you just
give me like brown rice
just like oh great oh no I've been my
first fecal excretion I get to have some
food that reminds me of it yeah so I got
I got that I got a steaming pile of that
um
congratulations on getting your period
Joey that'd be good yeah I'm sure it
tastes great I'm now a fully grown maybe
it'll last until you get a daughter
[Music]
I'll just hold on to it being like I got
this 30 years ago from a Christmas but
holding on to this is there any other
like Japanese Traditions like that
because I know there's like the coming
of age kind of like
um ceremony right uh the drink which one
right you just drank you just drink you
just get [ __ ] faced is that what is it
that that is all you do you do drink
yeah I mean worldwide baby yeah there's
also uh which is like it's this ceremony
that you do when your child turns either
three five or seven oh yeah I've heard
this
um and uh and I don't know exactly what
happens in it because I I never did it
um but both Childs are boys
they're crazy no I think it could be
either gender right yeah there's a boy's
boy thing right as well there's like a
boy celebration something I can't
[ __ ] remember what it is the penis
fist not the penis vessel what's the
thing when you put the you put the
little fish out the fish uh oh
nobody that's there that's uh children's
day oh maybe children yeah that's May
the fifth and we we for some reason we
we we we put up these like huge uh koi
like the koi fish yeah decorations and
we put them on like a top of a flagpole
and it's just kind of as like a mock-up
flag I don't know what this resemblance
there's a lot of things in Japan there's
a lot of weird holidays like that in
Japan there's also hinamatsudi which is
like the little dolls as well children
as well
um yeah I don't know lots of lots of
celebrations for children
has a child because they had a
population they have none so they're
like yeah it's just like uh we don't
know what to celebrate uh children it's
a momentous occasion when someone's like
oh you desire to have kids in Japan I
experienced something truly Japanese the
other day gone right gotcha
what gotcha like you must experience in
the weirdest way ever okay so I I rented
a car and there's an option on the
website that was called gacha rent a car
where you just rent a car and you have
no [ __ ] clue what car it is and you
only find out when you turn up that
sounds epic yeah so I I always rent the
smallest car anyway because I I never
have much luggage and when I'm doing
video shoots I just need something that
can get three people to a weird place
that a trainer doesn't go to so I always
just rent like a small car like a Toyota
Yaris or something right like a tiny car
fits for people yeah it has room for
bags and stuff and that's normally like
6 000 Yen just for the car for the day
so it's like it's like 45 bucks so
pretty cheap not bad um and then on the
website I saw it was like oh but for 4
000 Yen so for 30 bucks basically like
not even less than that I think now you
can get a random car for the day and I
thought well it can't be worse than the
yaros like it can't be worse than the
smallest car yeah and so I was like all
right [ __ ] it yeah I'll do it I'm down
so I turned out and I won the gacha dude
do you get the SSR no I don't get SSR I
got a pretty decent I got a [ __ ]
Toyota Prius when I turned up okay and I
was like I'll take a break I'll take a
Prius that's kind of like a win-win
right because if you're always going if
you're if you're always going for the
three star anyway then it's only going
to go up from there right yeah literally
I'm literally pulling for the most dog
[ __ ] thing normally so I'm like hey if I
get what's to say the three stars the
lowest right what if you show up and
it's like here's your bicycle
yeah I think the way it works is
whatever because obviously people
bringing cars back I think it's whatever
car is just kind of like awkwardly kind
of at that rent a car where someone else
doesn't need it yet so don't transfer it
you just kind of get it so I'm going to
turn a Prius and I was like oh that's
[ __ ] awesome yeah less price as well
yeah the Prius is normally 100 bucks a
day oh hello so I was like [ __ ]
that's [ __ ] dude you got it but I did
have to Google how to uh I was in the
car the Prius I'd never driven a Prius
before and I couldn't [ __ ] find the
handbrake I was like how the [ __ ] do I
get this the handbrake right so I'm
sitting in the thing and the guy's
asking me like oh you know how to drive
this right yeah
a [ __ ] car I don't have to drive it
it's a [ __ ] Prius puts it in a drive
it's not moving what the [ __ ] is it not
is it the foot pedal one is it yeah I've
never seen them on these before Oh
really I've literally never been in the
car where it's a foot pedal uh handbrake
yeah and and so I I'm in the car and the
guy the the car hose with me and my
cameraman he's like do you know do you
know how to get it out of the handbrake
I was like I have no [ __ ] clue so I'm
like hey Google how do I get the Prius
out of hand handbrake on and off and
then a YouTube video guys this is really
easy oh there's just a pedal at the
bottom there's a tiny little pedal yeah
you just push it in and then it's a
handbrake and I was like holy [ __ ] I've
never seen that before yeah my mom had a
Prius sign
have you have you ever seen that before
I've never seen it I've never seen it's
this tiny little hidden thing next to
like where the break is yeah right and
it's just this yeah tiny tiny like like
the [ __ ] size of this [ __ ] and you
just push it in and that's a handbrake
and I was like oh okay but I was great I
mean it was so cheap like with all the
gas and stuff I think the gas was only
like because it's a Prius
it was only like 20 bucks for gas oh
so the whole day the rental car was like
I just paid for
foreign
's great in Japan but there are a lot of
occasions where a car makes way more
sense yeah and so I you know we were
going to Fuji queue which you can get a
train robust you pretty easily but I
just want to be able to go there I wish
they would do that with all public
transport you know it's like it's like
okay so you want to get front to this
station take the train gotcha honestly
you won't know which train you're going
on I feel like we need more gotcha every
aspect let's see if it sounds like if
there was like let's say like on a plane
right there's 30 economy seats two
premium one business yeah and you can
just be like [ __ ] it oh my gosh but it's
a slightly more than economy like it's
slightly more you're like ah [ __ ] it
there's a chance I can itself play the
[ __ ] restaurant hey they should do it
go go to the restaurant and they give
you the menu and be like you can pay for
less but it's good
wine you could get the Dom Perignon well
you could get it or you could get a
Capri Sun
yeah because one of my one of my
favorite restaurants do actually have
like a gacha machine wait you took me to
it yeah yeah weird it's a catcher when
you leave oh really there's this Italian
restaurant uh and if you spend you know
a certain amount of money you get free
pools on the sketch machine and you can
buy you can win either like a free drink
or like a free meal or a lot of other
stuff so I don't know there's a lot of
uh izakayas that I've been to in Japan
uh where it's like it's kind of it's
kind of gotcha but it's like they use
like the dice rolling game I [ __ ]
love that game that's the Yakuza game
right yeah
like it's like two dice in in a in a
bowl yeah and uh like the one that's
near kind of my house is like you if you
buy a beer you can do chinchiro for it
which is where like depending on what's
thrown you can either get like a bigger
price for the same price or you can get
a bigger price for free or if you get
like two ones then you have to like do
five shots or it's like you know it's
like it's just this kind of like cool
fun little method to be like all right
let's see is that the game they because
I I learned how to play this game after
I watched
um kaiji yeah is it the same game
they're playing kaiji season two that's
just digital oh okay okay I love [ __ ]
it's a good game yeah it's really really
good game yeah I played it I played in
the bar Pete taught me how to play yeah
I went to a bar in Japan and the owner
would play chinchiro with you yeah yeah
and yeah if you lose I I I I lost some
time so if you lose you had to do the
shot of Jaeger yeah and then and so like
the bar owner lost like three times it
was like three shots of Jaeger it's
pretty fun it's a good game you should
Google how to play it I could explain
but it's it takes like a few minutes
there's lots of local rules as well
which is yeah basically basically roll
High yeah that's basically it like get
doubles yeah I went to I went to like a
craft beer place the other day that I
had a had a pretty cool system as well
so they you know you can obviously buy
just buy like normal like uh glasses and
normal pints and everything like that
but they also have the system the
special system where
um it's like one price for us like for
like a certain amount of drink right and
then it's kind of like a tier system so
this this drink will always be this one
price but if you can finish your string
you can order more of the same beer but
then the next the next beer you get is
going to be a bigger size in volume
and it gets to a point where he gets
like a comically big size of volume like
a [ __ ] bucket by the end that's like
the final tier
um I just I remember me and Cindy went
there and we were just like let's try
and do it let's let's try and complete
the game and it's it's I I want to take
someone makes that sometime just to see
like I just see like what what if we
take a breath there now what if we take
a [ __ ] take a trip like like a German
there see how far we get because we we
got to like the second to last tier and
we were like [ __ ] what was the vessel
what was the vessel yeah what was the
vessel it was like um are we talking
like a boot or yeah what was it it was
you know you know when you see like some
of that like you know that comically big
wine glass that's just like oh I'm only
gonna have one glass of wine
[Applause]
that was that was like the second to
last stage holy [ __ ] and then the final
stage was just a straight it was just
like a [ __ ] glass bucket almost it
like it was like kind of like a yard
basically I think there's a few of
places that do that gimmick in Japan
yeah because it's like I've been to one
like that in rapongi as well yeah
um that was we should we should do it to
see out of the three of us who can
complete it I I did beer last time I
went and I think that was a mistake
because like by the I think the second
one or third one I was really full yeah
yeah
I can't drink this bucket I can't drink
out of this it's not even fun to drink
anything yeah it just becomes not fast
I'd rather have a bunch of small glasses
the way everyone has been doing for a
very long time yeah it was fun for a
one-off yeah I mean I like going to
places where they're kind of like it's
it's they kind of just gamify something
whether it's like [ __ ] gotcha it's
like so much gacha [ __ ] here so much to
get your stuff in daily life yeah like
even like you go to Akihabara you can
play the Sketcher machine for like 10 20
bucks yeah and you might get something
but normally you get something kind of
yeah and yeah one thing one thing I've
never understood is uh
have you ever like you know gone to like
an anime convention right and you know
they have like those special mystery
boxes yeah right yeah that's one thing
I'd like that's that's one thing I've
never gotten and I don't understand why
people would get them because do you
think they actually put like good gifts
in there so I think it originated it's a
New Year's thing in Japan right it's how
it started and they're normally actually
pretty generous right like it's meant to
be like a lot of the times you have to
book these and they're limited a lot of
the times as well like especially some
of the more expensive ones like the ones
that you have to book like some of the
stuff in these uh lucky but they're
called but like in this like there's a
lot of stuff where you can only get it
in the lucky bag like it's not sold
anywhere else it's like a special like
package but like you won't know what it
is until you get it right I got one last
time from amiami it was 500 bucks and I
definitely got more than 500 worth of
figures in the Box the Pokemon one for
example the Pokemon's in every year like
you have to book that [ __ ] like four
months Jesus I didn't realize you had to
book this year man of course yeah it's
Japan uh yeah you have to all the good
ones you have to book but you also
generally it's more like a celebratory
thing than a let's make a lot of money
it's like all right that's that's just
like happy New Year yes happy New Year
because you know New Year's one of the
biggest things in Japan and then I think
uh you know
um when American consort they're like
money is this a money-making and ax was
always that one booth I can't remember
which one it was there was that one
where they would make the Walls World
the lucky boxes remember these yeah the
animation right there that just have a
like a booth that was made out of these
lucky boxes yeah I remember that and
dude you just they have never had
anything good enough never never they're
good for Content that's about it even
then like move down or edited a video of
I think with uh hard on unboxing one of
them but it's just the saddest thing
ever and it was like 50 bucks nothing
nothing good in it he gave me like a
squid game plush that wouldn't shut up
there's like a tiny one yeah you press
it
whatever the [ __ ] inside yeah yeah I
was like oh my God this is so [ __ ]
it's funny oh man what's normal to do in
Japan for like New Year's what's like
the tradition here the tradition is to
you have to go to like a temple right
yeah Temple oh that's usually a news day
okay
um but like for me like this year I'm
going back to my Grandma's place up
north uh because like it's very much
like it's weird like Christmas and you
mean you already went to your Grandma's
place yeah it's the New Years the New
Year fantastic I loved it
um yeah so I think it's it's interesting
because like I thought about this it's
like Christmas and New Year's how it's
celebrated in the west is like the
complete opposite to how to celebrate in
Japan yeah because it's like in the west
it's like Christmas is for the family
and then New Year's is where you get
sloshed with your mates right right but
in Japan it's the opposite Christmas is
like a couple's thing or you get sloshed
with your single friends
I've been there yeah and New Year's is
when you go back home and you spend it
with your family all right right and so
like at least for me like the tradition
is like usually I go back to my
Grandma's place like a few days before
New Year's Eve and then we do like a big
like final cleanup of the house to kind
of like you know not to like physically
clean up the house but also just like to
refresh ourselves like you know for the
upcoming year that's what they say yeah
you come in and clean my house right
yeah it's just an excuse for my grandma
to be my clean my house [ __ ]
um so I go there I clean the house and
then
um we have this thing called
which is uh which is you have this bowl
of soba uh as your final meal
um and uh for the year not yeah
yeah it's uh and uh I don't remember
what the exact reasoning behind why you
eat the strawberries but there's like
some kind of uh like traditional
reasoning behind why you would do it um
so then you would eat that and then the
New Years happens then you go to the
temple first thing in the morning
usually uh to do like you know your
first prayers and stuff like that and
then you eat osichi which is like a type
of uh traditional Japanese like huge
[ __ ] platter of like I think like 50
different things like small little
different things like imagine what you
get I think I've seen this you can I've
seen this to be able to book it yeah
I've seen it yeah you usually usually
you book it I mean people who are like
pros just like make it themselves
um but like uh think of like you know
like the breakfast at a dualcon think of
that by like four times yeah yeah and
you share it among your entire
and it's really good but it's like it's
definitely something you can't have is
it is it like the chocolate boxes where
there's like Everyone likes a certain
the one chocolate and everyone's like
yeah I have yo can I have that yeah can
I have like that and then I'm good I
don't want the [ __ ] squid [ __ ] I'm
good yeah there's always like there's
always like two or three that are just
like untouched
looks nice it's just there for variation
help yourself
um I feel like there are some real items
that people just buy just for like oh
it's just because everyone else bought
it before yeah do you have um like
quality Street in Australia what's up
okay [ __ ] that's a British thing quality
slate quality street so you have a
quality high quality Street yeah it's
like uh kind of like uh just a different
type of chocolates right it's a lot of
these are the different colored ones yes
yeah there's like there's like a
triangle that's perfect yeah I've seen
it before I think yeah and and I think
there was a certain episode of Qi that
was like they everyone the favor pieces
that Everyone likes they purposely put
Less in the box of which is [ __ ] is
cruel it's cruel is that true yeah
[ __ ]
yeah these swindled Bamboozled I was
like that's [ __ ] up bro that's just a
waste of food man you could you could
have more chocolate if people are easy
there if they don't want to put the good
stuff in because that's expensive damn
it's annoying they probably do that with
uh yeah they probably did that with like
a bunch of different ones right I'm sure
do you have celebrations yeah okay you
have those we have those yeah I've shot
any Americans best ones non-british
people are like what the [ __ ]
celebrations there's only like two of
the best ones what is it what is the
best best two in the celebrations
actually like most of the celebrations I
like most of them but the the malteser
one is the best Maltese there's like a
chocolate malteser one what what
chocolates are in there this is so
British now yeah we're going to British
chocolates okay but like it might be
different because like do you guys have
cherry ripe the [ __ ] is that okay that's
Australian what the [ __ ] is that that's
the best one yeah see Kai knows what's
up what is it explain that to me cherry
ripe is uh it's this it's this chocolate
bar that has like kind of I don't know I
don't even know what the hell it is it's
this cherry flavored something inside of
it it's like Cherry chocolate
um I I actually don't know what it is I
don't care what it is it's delicious
yeah okay so in British celebrations uh
it's kind of like a box of different
kind of famous chocolate bars just like
in very very tiny candy form
um so we have maltesers Mars Bars Twix
Snickers yeah Milky Way bouncy Galaxy
and uh Galaxy caramel and I think galaxy
is the best
yes nah dude maltesers teasers are the
goat dude if you haven't you got to have
one of these
um if you come to the UK at some point
I'm sure we because we eat it outside
but it's a very very festive thing as
well people buy them okay that's so
[ __ ] good yeah they advertise hard
for the holidays dude okay I don't know
if it's a white people thing but they're
in like every white person's home I
mean I didn't even know that I didn't
know that yeah after talking to God so
much I'm like ah I have to reframe how I
view the UK I'm like no no it's not the
UK it's the it's the white people it's
the white people
because I only have experienced the UK
through the lens of white people because
I'm obviously White
yeah I mean it's it's kind of like me
with Easter chocolates where I I [ __ ]
that this is overrated
this is I I like the Easter chocolates I
don't know why and you could you could
have like a like a cadre's Milk Bar uh
milk chocolate bar and I'm like I will
buy the egg version eating it in egg
form I don't know just tastes makes it
taste so much better I don't know what
did something about like slowly breaking
off it is it is right it is I don't know
why this is a thing but this is so
[ __ ] British that I'm saying out loud
often when you buy these uh these uh
Easter eggs in the UK they come in these
boxes for some reason they always come
with mugs
they would like you would get an Easter
egg that would come with a mug that was
branded like it was Cadbury's it would
be a mug a very cheap mug with the
Cadbury's logo on it right and this was
a thing like did you have this in
Australia so this was like it was you'd
always get the chocolate bar and a mug
do you remember this I remember this
yeah and then I realized like oh wait I
just remembered in University everyone
would bring mugs and stuff and I swear
half the [ __ ] mugs were just Easter
egg mugs because they're the cheapest
shittest mugs that your parents wouldn't
mind letting you take to you right do
you remember seeing these now all the
time in University now that you're
mining now that you remind me I'm just
having a lot [ __ ] yeah you're the wave I
remember I see the [ __ ] Cadbury and
KitKat logo on these [ __ ] mugs all
the time dude it looks so [ __ ] let me
pull it up I'm gonna pull this up it
looks so pathetic
imagine Easter eggs mugs it's those ones
it's those ones God
it would come like this it would come
like this right it's like it would it
would be the egg in the mug or like
adjacent to it and this was like I've
never seen that yeah it was everywhere
like every single [ __ ] chocolate bar
did this it was insane and now I think
about them like why the [ __ ] do we want
so many mugs this is too many mugs for
the team yeah but I already have mugs
that's that's the thing about every like
British home there is oh there was there
is always an overabundance of mugs oh
sorry it's and there's the nice mugs and
these are the shittiest the shits and if
you ever go to like a government
building or you ever go to a hospital
and or any kind of thing and you get a
cup of tea guaranteeing it's coming out
in a mug the exact same quality as this
one thank God because they're like
they're like the replaceable marks yeah
because like the actual good mugs no one
gets those no one's allowed so once
you're finished with that we just Chuck
it on the wall probably before you throw
it away did you ever have like did your
household ever had like a soft tier list
of like mugs in your home you know you
know you have like the cheap ones but
when you like want to treat yourself
yeah you have like your purse there was
there was like two or three mugs whereas
my dad was just like those are my
[ __ ] months don't touch it because it
was like some mugs were like China like
with some nice quality yeah but they're
still Murray's and whenever I used it my
mum wanted a cup of tea she's like why
do you keep using the mug I like that's
my mind I'm like I thought you weren't
gonna have a tea so I took it I I just
thought it was okay because you're such
a good mom like I swear to God every
British person has like everything
everyone has a favorite has that one mug
where's they become like Sheldon from
Big Bang oh yeah it's just like don't
use this mug this is my mug we have
every British person is like this
because everyone drinks so much [ __ ]
teal coffee that you need a mug you need
the goat mug and I yeah I like ones that
are like I've come to become very fond
of like deep very like cylindrical mugs
not the ones that like curve up just
just a [ __ ] cylinder chop it off boom
big mug I hate the ones that like curve
up like those ones they're [ __ ] like
teacup looking ones yeah I'm not a big
fan of those I just want this like
literally a perfect cylinder just chop
chop it in half boom that's the model
give it to me I like the uh kind of like
oval shaped ones yeah they're pretty
like that oh like like yeah like this
one like the kind of dump people yeah
like literally like this one maybe like
a little bigger yeah kind of kind of
feels like I'm drinking from the
Medieval ages or something I don't know
about that's not medieval
I mean some of the designs I have in my
house also my mum has so much [ __ ]
yeah your dude your mom has a collection
your Mom Mom's house feels like a Looney
Tunes accident waiting ahead it is you
go you walk in and you're like I can't
touch anything if I touch a wall
everything will break it's like a fully
artist nightmare between VR in the
living room with this [ __ ] China all
over the world hard mode to explain my
mom like for my entire life as let's say
had this hobby of uh collecting
um kind of like antique kind of like
very uh there's a word for it now
because it's kind of become a trend
let's come back in fashion now yeah it's
kind of like very bougie kind of like
teacups and China and stuff like that uh
so my entire life
um I felt like my I was surrounded by uh
like Jenga pieces or the and if if I
would make the wrong move then the
entire house would come falling down you
know that's that's how I feel and I I
kind of just got used to it until people
like started coming around my house and
everything like that people with the
mugs and people like it's like what's up
with all this China Mouse what's up with
that like when whenever you would like
come home drunk you must be just [ __ ]
sweating
it's like a mission impossible like
Dodge the lasers thing I was just like I
need to get into my room but there are
mugs everywhere yeah I got the
earthquake uh UK doesn't have
earthquakes oh this is the only game
over this would not work in Japan no I I
don't think like I don't know how I can
properly verbalize just
how much how many like pressure that's
just like Antiques and like mugs it like
goes up the stairs she she has literally
like filled up every wall with like nice
Fine China like my plates okay we don't
have posters I don't I never grew up
with having posters or paintings in my
wall my walls were filled with plates
and China glasses okay that's that's
what my walls for oh and yeah by
complete by complete I don't know who
feels coincidence or Nice Like luck
they've come into fashion so she's uh
ended up being like she's like selling
she's able to like turn this Hobby and
uh turn it into like kind of like a
hobby where she can make money out of
because holy [ __ ] people people buy this
for like a [ __ ] ridiculous price in
Asia oh yeah yeah it's I I I don't I
hope I'm hoping none of my mom's
customers watch this because they buy it
for like a very very high price I'm like
[ __ ] I saw you buy this for 50
pence on the car boot sale what wait
flying demand man man
it's like a lifetime's well like I could
see my lifetimes worth my mom going to
car boot sales buying this [ __ ] for like
50p a pound a piece like that's not
gonna come back I like selling it for
like a God knows the amount of money on
that man Jesus Christ inflation yeah
good on your mum but please keep selling
them because I want my house back I want
to walk in my house and not feel like
I'm going to break something Jesus so
yeah it's uh it's
yeah it was it was it was slightly weird
growing up with that kind of environment
okay actually this is the this doesn't
remind me about a totally different
topic okay
decorating a room right
my room my house was always decorated
with as I said like teacups and places
something like that so I never really
got to like let's say I never really got
to a point where I knew what to do with
decorating my own room I never had
posters I never had like different
things in my room to like show my own
personality what like
I'm I'm guessing you put a lot of like
music posters in your room and stuff
yeah that right I I don't even know how
to get posters
what do you mean how do I get them what
do you mean just go you go to stores I
don't have money we're getting this
money from that there were like three
bucks no like the good push like five
pounds in the UK you don't get the good
ones you get the [ __ ] ones so I only
ever put shitty posters up when I came
like a magazine for free yeah and I I
think I also that's why you start off
yeah I think I got a free
a poster of Halo and like Halo Reach or
something and I put that [ __ ] on did you
did you ever have trouble like
decorating your room in University
because I didn't decorate my room you
didn't at all no it was a little like a
Serial Killer's room I I had nothing on
the walls nothing I I didn't get in my
head I was like why would I decorate
like I'm leaving this room in a year oh
that's true that's true but I've seen
some University rooms and they are like
filled to the [ __ ] brim with like
different stuff and I was like how the
[ __ ] are you affording this yeah I think
I never decorated ever
had like one poster and that was it it
was okay I think I think I bought one
poster just so like if anyone came in
here they wouldn't think they were going
into a super chemistry it was I think it
was like a [ __ ] start Scarface poster
I was just like let me buy something
from like the university fair and I was
like what's something I can buy that's
cheap that would also make me feel like
a normal person scar faces Scarface is
that poster that's on the brink of like
I'm a normal person but I'm a little bit
quirky
he was just waiting for the Wolf of Wall
Street to come out yeah
because I was like well
I can't put anime on my wall that's
that's that's that's
out of the question that just means uh
that just means I'm just going to be
shunned from every social group in
Universe back when anime wasn't accepted
so I was like how do I let me pretend to
be a normal human let me scientifically
work this out what is something I can
put on my wall that's like oh I got a
little bit of Personality
quirky it's either Scarface or Pulp
Fiction
choices like either Scarface or Pulp
Fiction and that was it I just always
wanted to spend my money on food so I
thought I'm not gonna decorate my room
it's dumb I'm also like if I'm moving
like every year yeah what's the point in
decorating I just put a PC in my room
did you move every year uh yeah every
single year of University I moved oh
[ __ ] oh wow okay so the first year I was
in student dorms I'm in the UK I don't
know if I was in your University in mine
uh you're only allowed to be in student
dorms for one year and then you had to
find your own accommodation ah and then
obviously because like you know some
roommates dropped out and some roommates
yeah you know whatever like people
changed so I just always moved every
year yeah when I was only in University
for three years yeah so you know I was I
was living at home so I was just like
decorating my own room like I had this
like weird conversation with Sydney the
other day
um because like Sydney was like Sydney
Cindy found this like [ __ ] up movie
icebergs here this kind of thing and I
think I've watched that we've watched
that I think yeah it's not like the two
and a half hour one on YouTube no she
just found like the image of it right oh
and I come home and she was like I'm I'm
thinking about like going through this
Iceberg I was like Sydney don't don't do
not [ __ ] do that
um because I I I I I don't really like
horror movies and I'm not really like I
don't really have like I have morbid
curiosity but I've never I've been but
you also have a sense of reason I also
have a sense of reason as well but I
ended up I I looked at the iceberg tier
list and I ended up realizing that I've
seen a lot of this a lot of these movies
and the reason because of that uh is
because uh when I went to University
there was a phase where people like like
your roommates you always knew that I'm
[ __ ] one guy that would try to like
show you the most [ __ ] up thing that
they could find whether it be something
like a Serbian film or other like things
they found on something on like Reddit
50 50 or something yeah and Sydney had
just like never experienced that so I
was like I was like realizing is this is
this a me thing that no happened in my
face yeah it's either in high school or
in college like you had that one yeah it
was in high school for me it was like
that one kid that was just like
it made me wonder if it's still a phase
because I think it became a phase
because of [ __ ] like you know two girls
one cup and everything like that so I'm
like do the good old days it's it's like
anyone in University you know anyone in
college or high school is there is this
still a thing for sure where are you
guys still showing each other two girls
as long as long as there's the internet
if someone wants to be a little age Lord
of course involved right that's that's
how life is God I saw some of the most
traumatic [ __ ] in high school just
because of that one [ __ ] friend yeah
to that one friend who is not a friend
anymore [ __ ] you like you've literally
scarred me for life of some of the [ __ ]
that you've shown me yeah I do not want
to like I don't know oh no it's horrible
yeah
foreign
myself up for Christmas yeah I'm gonna
gain a lot of weight on purpose I'm
gonna do it I'm gonna gain so much
weight I just eat and drink like a
[ __ ] on the holidays just don't
stop I I've become like no face in that
one
I've even seen that movie so I don't
even know what to happen in there well
you've never seen Spirited Away no what
no
oh
what what
are you actually serious yeah I like how
you talked about that with such
confidence and familiarity I'm like I've
seen that [ __ ] my [ __ ] no face
I've seen that gift like a billion
[ __ ] times have you actually never
seen it never seen it that's shocking
yeah for a long time I just lied and
said I did because I I because I think I
remember you saying you have told me
yeah probably probably because I was
just kind of like uh you know it's like
saying you haven't watched Death Note
right what the [ __ ] have you watch Death
Note you know it's like what I just
don't care too I've watched last night
yeah I remember you saying you have
watched death yeah I just lied uh I
think one time we had a conversation
where you were like oh yeah Princess
Monarchy it's so dark yeah yeah but I've
never watched Princess Mononoke either
have you seen any Ghibli film never I've
never watched My Neighbor Totoro either
yeah
why is that the one because that's
purely like driven off Nostalgia the
only Ghibli film I've watched and this
is within the past five years I only
watched as well before that I hadn't
even watched any it was like uh Howl's
Moving Castle oh yeah and Kiki's
Delivery service okay that was kind of
mid
it's all right I like it so yeah I never
watched uh Spirited Away okay if you
like Hal's movie Castle you'll like
Spirited Away yeah I mean like hell's
Moving Castle yeah I liked howl okay how
was the game
yeah yeah Christian Bell right that's
Christian Bale it's Christian Bale yes
Christian Bale [ __ ] off that's
Christians Christians what the [ __ ] you
used to go man what can't he do what
what can't Christian Bale do I swear to
God man he does everything I love those
moments where you're just like talking
about a movie that you love and then
someone says like yeah did you know his
voice by that guy and it's just like
I had no idea that was Christian Bale
well it's a bit to be fair it's really
[ __ ] hard to tell he's so [ __ ]
good at disappearing into the character
yeah like I don't like he's a Welshman
right and I you can never tell that he's
a Welshman I swear he has like a
different accent everything I think he
was born in Wales then immediately moved
to uh London I think or America he's got
a I remember he spoke about it once
right yeah I think he was born it's
funny though how so many people just
like yeah he's American right well I
mean he's so [ __ ] good at up here
yeah
yeah have you watched any uh have you
watched chainsaw man uh yeah I'm I'm uh
Nine episodes in oh my God I like you so
far it's it's a it's something man it's
I'm kind of glad that we finally got a
show that was hyped and so far has been
following through like I every episode
is a delight it's [ __ ] weird it's
just insane every episode is like a
movie budget it's it's a lot crazy the
fact that there's a different ending
every time as well like I it's kind of
insane I'm I am blown away it's [ __ ]
sweaty yeah yeah oh [ __ ] we gotta live
up to that it's kind of crazy even as
like I even if I wasn't a fan of the
show it's like you're watching it you're
like there's you just can't not be
amazed by it like oh yeah you don't
enjoy it it's [ __ ] insane yeah oh the
story is crude sometimes but let's just
I like it I think it's fun I mean I I
like it's it's obviously a bit edgier
than like a lot for sure for sure it
feels like edgy yeah but I don't feel
like it's like edgy for the sake of
being like edgy like we've seen with
like some other shows you know where
just like oh this is the show that's
aimed towards 15 year olds that you know
want to think they're watching something
adult no it's clearly just like Fujimoto
just being like I don't give a [ __ ] if
people like this or not like this is
just how I'm gonna make my story and how
I'm gonna make my characters yeah yeah
the I was kind of amazed at one point
episode nine the episode before ends
with the scene and then they reused the
scene in The Next Episode but they
reanimate it very slightly entirely all
over again and I'm like okay now this is
that's too much that's just a waste like
this is insane but this is like what and
it's all insane animation like yeah it's
it's like I don't understand how how
much money or time power costing money
again I go and travel
like I mean the amount of time money and
effort put into this is must be another
level like the amount talent that must
have gone into this is insane what blows
my mind is when you know when people
like look at something and think good
animation they think oh the fight scene
was like good or they they think of the
fight scene like chainsaw man just looks
good in like everything the talking
scenes oh my God it's so [ __ ] every
shot is so like Dynamic right it's it's
like you know sometimes you watch an
anime it's just like always like oh
basic shot for shot for sure there's
always that always feels like there's
some thought and to put some thought put
into how this like how this looks on
films like what angle have we not put a
camera at yet wait let's do it let's do
it from there like I know you've read
the Manga but you you need to watch the
anime I am watching it oh you are
watching it of course I I can't
I kind of have to I don't I think I
would actually be hung in quartered
anime is so good that I'm like I really
don't want to touch the manga I'm like
this this is what I'm saying I know I
bet it is but like watching the anime
I'm like there's no first season's only
gonna end halfway so probably probably
yeah I think the manga is as good as the
anime I agree I've been doing something
like a little quirky I've been watching
uh watching the anime then read in the
manga oh okay shut the [ __ ] up guys
don't [ __ ] say that [ __ ] [ __ ] what
are you [ __ ] why the [ __ ] could you
do that why would you do that why
um because why why did that because
anime is my medium of choice if I have a
choice um and the anime is doing an
amazing production but I think uh
tatsuki Fujimoto the mangaka is an
absolute [ __ ] genius I agree uh he
uses manga in a way that no other manga
artists I think has done he has such a
unique way of conveying like his ideas
and emotions and it's a way that is
impossible to replicate in any other
medium because he's able to draw it in a
way that looks and feels cinematic yeah
which I think is really hard to do in
the medium of manga like because you
know again it's like a lot like with a
lot of anime it's like you have your bog
standard like you know flow of panels
and like you know maybe every now and
then there'll be an artist they'll be
like Oh I'm gonna draw outside of the
panel like literally outside of the
panel to kind of add like Dynamic to it
but like fujimota just kind of draws it
in a way where it's just like
this flows in a really smooth way but
it's also a really strange feeling yeah
at the same time like now that I've like
read like what's been adapted so far and
uh in in the manga I'm like how the [ __ ]
does tatsuki Fujimoto have better
comedic timing in the manga which has no
comedic timing than in the anime right
it's he he's the job he's done with is
like the way he's like paneled and laid
out his page it like this the scenes in
among there are like some funny scenes
that are like way funnier I think in the
manga than in the anime
um and it's just because of the way that
he's kind of like timed it really well
with how like you turn the page and
stuff like you have any examples that
you might be able to think of um I can't
think of off the top of my head if you
did yeah I think there's there's a few
things that I think have like are
impossible to translate to the anime
like one of one thing I can think of is
um how can I say this without spoiling
anything that happens
so there is there is a weapon that
involves a nail right uh if if you've
what if you're like you you've nine I'm
on episode nine episode you should have
seen it then there's a there's a weapon
that involves a nail
maybe it's it's like it's like a demon
kind of thing right a nail as in this
nail
okay all right
no I haven't I don't know I don't oh
this nail oh I'm doing something that
involves this obviously something that
involves this
yeah you definitely have
have I yeah maybe did you think it was a
sword
maybe it was a sword
maybe you should I [ __ ] I don't know
all right okay we'll carry on yeah yeah
but uh there's a scene where he uses
this weapon
um and obviously it's a weapon that's
like infused with a demon right yeah so
there's this there's this like really
cool panel where
um like to use this weapon you have to
have a contract with a devil that's what
every that's what every weapon is right
and so how he portrays that this weapon
is controlled by this devil is that you
have you have like the normal panels and
that's how it is throughout the entire
manga every comic book and then when he
uses this uh when he uses weapon the a
finger just appears from that goes from
like outside of like the Box panels
right and so it kind of like flicks from
out of frame into frame and you're like
it's cool oh that's really [ __ ] cool
to be like oh there's something that's
being like called out from like outside
this world and [ __ ] like that and I'm
like you can't really do that in anime
because it's it's you know okay I don't
have boxes and [ __ ] like that but it's
like small things like that where he
really thinks about how do I like how do
I how do I do something that it's really
cool that only manga can do and he does
this in not just like me not just
chainsaw man but pretty much everything
I've read from him he does something
unique to manga that I've not seen
anywhere else
um and that's true especially if you've
not read like I would highly recommend
goodbye Arie which is like one shot you
can read that okay within like that is
so genius yeah and I was like I've never
I've never read something that is just
like so it's it's a masterpiece in my
mind so [ __ ] genius yeah I mean yeah
gentleman I've loved it so far I think
it yeah it's it's crazy to see uh
because again we've had hyped up shows
but I don't think we've had a show
that's been this hyped up in so long I
don't think ever yeah and um yeah it's
insane to see it kind of meeting it and
kind of crushing it because it goes I
was a bit worried because I remember
watching like the first six episodes I'm
like this is cool but it's kind of like
your standard yeah standard affair right
now yeah from episode like five six
onwards it definitely got way more
excited yeah
um and it's been like so fun watching it
yeah but also I'm sad that I have to
wait every week uh I'm I'm sad that
we're gonna have to wait for a season
two yeah hopefully hopefully
is the manga finished uh part one of the
manga is finished so he's currently
writing so he went on a little bit of a
break after part one and now he's
starting up part two again oh okay yeah
I did get a chuckle out of I guess it's
not really spoiler but like at one point
that like the name of a demon is is
means it's strength or something and
they're like what's what's the scariest
thing a chainsaw in a garden I was like
what I was like what
you have this like really intensely like
really edgy built up world they're like
gun strong
I was like all right that stuff doesn't
really spoil anything it's just yeah
it's just funny even like I was like
what yeah I don't think it's not wrong
but things just get more and more
intense in the morning
I've never watched the show and actually
said what the [ __ ] out loud so many
times like this [ __ ] happens you're like
God and the second half of the manga is
just like I believe it I believe it's
like the last two or three volumes are
just insane I'm just like I don't what
I'm I'm very happy I'm very excited uh
wait is it 12 episodes they're doing or
12 episodes [ __ ] I know I know in fact
the 24th I know bring back the two core
okay I'll take the same ending let's
just get a few more episodes in come on
that's like a whole episode of Animation
we can do come on let's get more
episodes I don't need the ending every
time the time yeah yeah I really hope we
don't have to wait too long for another
season because it's I think we are this
is I think we are if there was it's been
a while since I've watched a show and
I'm like 12 up that's that's it that's
it 12 episodes I've never been breaked
up through the entire show like that
before yeah like from start to finish
like the food I'm like I'm Rock Solid
when they show food in the show the food
looks so good that's perfect I've never
been more [ __ ] bricked up watching a
hand-holding scene oh right right holy
[ __ ] man like talk about like Awakening
something I'm like I thought this was a
meme I thought hand holding hands I was
a meme man they actually [ __ ] made it
a thing dude every character has awoke
with something you never wants yeah it's
I've never I'm impressed that they've
managed to make a character who is that
horny likable I I figured anyone that
horny in real life would would uh sorry
in any show normally if a character is
just super horny it's like like meliodas
yeah I [ __ ] hate them yeah they
[ __ ] suck but that's the thing that
that's what another thing with Fujimoto
that I think is genius is that like not
just chainsaw man but everything he's
written every character is an absolute
piece of [ __ ] yeah but he's somehow able
to turn these absolute [ __ ]
detestable piece of [ __ ] characters
likable well it's like in real in real
life right most people agree like most
people do bad things so they do good
things right so it's like if you can
kind of channel that and I feel like
that's where it's it's doing that great
like it so far changed some man all the
characters don't feel like they good bad
it's like all right you know they're
again maybe they've got a lot of
problems maybe maybe they're a bad
person but they do some good things but
I've seen I've also seen a lot of anime
where they just like they try and make
like a like a purposeful like shitty
character right yeah like oh okay you
know all the all the edgy people are
gonna enjoy this one and then it just
ends up being extremely annoying yeah I
mean this could easily be like a Mirai
Nikki situation exactly it's like haha
Edge
everyone is shitty everyone 20 and we're
all gonna stab each other and it's like
all right well it's it's kind of like
it's I I think he strikes that perfect
balance where he pretty much every
character and change the mind it's kind
of like an [ __ ] yeah absolutely but
yeah it's like it's like an entertaining
[ __ ] because they're all trying to
survive right yeah so it's like you know
how would you act if you had to survive
yeah in this in this world that is very
[ __ ] up yeah like like just like I
remember the scene where they were all
like trapped in the building together oh
yeah just [ __ ] chaos and I was just
like I was just like it feels like
watching a scene from Always Sunny in
Philadelphia
yeah
because it was just like why am I having
such a good time just seeing these guys
try to survive it's it's been
complaining yeah they're in like a life
and death situation and they're just
like it's just [ __ ] bands man just
when Danger's like I'm going to sleep
I [ __ ] love that scene it's like bro
who's that scene where uh one of the
girls like freaking out I would just
like like burst like full-on burst out
laughing and I was just like what it's
just it's just [ __ ] it's a [ __ ]
riot man so good oh it's yeah it's been
a long time since I've been this excited
for an anime I just hope they don't give
me a reason to ever dislike the show so
far I'm pretty happy yeah to be honest
nah I mean even the second half as
chaotic as it gets like it's just so
intense and insane where it's just like
of course this is how it is and I think
like the like complaints about CG that
I've seen on Twitter
oh no dude there's like barely any CG
and then when it is it's like it's good
I think the most awkward looking shots
were like in episode one yeah and then
like they still use CG in like other
flies and it just they've managed to
blend it a lot better but even in
episode one it was like it looked a bit
dodgy here and there like a few shorts
but didn't look bad you know I've seen
bad CG I've seen Exxon
I've seen extra
she's watching it I was like this should
be such a different show from set in
America
wait what do you mean okay okay very
very quick kind of I guess life spoiler
not really yeah there's like a whole
scene where there's a bunch of guns
involved I was like they were like the
superpower is gone I was like I was like
well yeah I guess that makes sense that
makes sense and I was like this this is
an America this would be really
different by now this would be a really
different show
my superpower is gone there's literally
like a scene in the video he's like
everything gun beats everything and I
was like yeah
it's like
miniguns are legal in Texas
this finna will be 12 episodes in
America dude oh my God no this is fun it
was just a good time it's just fun it
was fun oh my God so many shows in anime
are
very much saved by the fact they're set
in Japan because there are no guns yeah
if they were in America could you
imagine if my hero Academia was set in
America it's like go save him Deku oh
[ __ ] he's got an AK
a porn might be like oh no back again
was shot by a Barrett 50 caliber he
can't recover yeah Fortnight yeah
yeah I just I just I just it just made
me realize how many shows are more
believable in terms of realistic
somewhat because they're not because
they're set in Japan yeah yeah you get
away with this because you're in Japan
yeah yeah you wouldn't need a superhero
organization was an American death note
if there was just guns as well like if
there was more guns like Al just had a
gun the entire time which I feel would
have been way shorter like no
it's like oh you're Kira
are you like so many it just made me
realize how many shows could have been
quicker if there was Guns yeah
basically you've just like erased every
Shonen from existence
Kuroko no basket you know but he hasn't
gone
I I watched um I obviously I've read all
uh all of the parts of Jojo except for
the last part
um and I I was re-watching uh Stone
ocean and I remember I was like oh yeah
there is a whole part about lynching in
it yeah and I was like that's I and I
was watching I was like this is weird
watching this in Japanese
with like an over-the-top narrated
narrating about how somebody you know
how about like racial tensions in
Florida I was like this is really weird
and I was like I don't remember that
yeah right there's a whole there's a
character's whole backstory where a
character you know uh was Lynch and it
was talking about how racist and it was
really odd because the narrator narrates
about racism in Florida and it was very
weird seeing them how they handled
narrating it in Japanese yeah yeah
because it was um I can't remember how
they did it but I remember it was a bit
odd yeah and I was like yeah I guess
there's one way of mentioning how it all
works that is yeah that does that is
that is what happened yeah that is what
happened it was just kind of like a
normal anime thing and then it goes but
did you forget that this is 19th 1980s
Florida and this racial Prejudice is
like whoa Iraqi where is this coming
from what the [ __ ]
Rocky watched 12 years of slave
we just it was just like funny Plankton
go he he punching and then it goes and
then it just goes straight into that and
you're like what the [ __ ] it's like a
documentary yeah it was just kind of
like whoa Iraqi like and just seeing it
animated just reminded me like oh yeah
this yeah yeah okay this is this is set
in America they really wanted to use
that setting here that was all right
okay all right a bit intense yeah
because like every time every time I've
seen like portrayals of like say like
racism in uh anime and manga it's always
tough it's always tough right it's it's
yeah it's always tough and especially
like real like seeing like Jojo part six
you know in we've we've seen we've seen
stories portrayed
um you know in Western media and
something and I still I feel like
there's like a kind of like it's
powerful but it's also if it said in the
modern day it can be like subtle as well
you know yeah but every every time I see
it in [ __ ] anime and manga it's
always the most in your face look at
racism this is racism I think because
like if you if you go back and look at
movies of like 2000s and 90s yeah that
was kind of how you know a lot of these
big Hollywood Productions are kind of
portraying racism it's like look we can
solve it with a movie and a good speech
like it's it's fixed yeah and I think
that that kind of way of looking at it
was kind of because obviously the
conversation isn't nearly as prevalent
here in Japan yeah things like that kind
of way of viewing it and talking about
it was kind of taken into how anime does
it yeah or sometimes it's just flat a
racist in anime like gants that's just
weird yeah like that I mean you know
that happens in anime sometimes my
favorite is the Last Arc initial 21.
that one is so poorly yeah it's not good
it's very nice and it's very nice it's
ashamed it's like damn it like it's such
a good artist obviously like this stuff
was was written at a time when this was
barely a conversation in in the west
yeah like Stone ocean was written I
think early 2000s 2003 right before this
was this this conversation was like you
know barely started in the western world
yeah and then now looking at it through
our modern lens of how we view it and
how we talk about these topics it's like
oh yeah that's a bit yeah I mean it's
like it's like the way okay but by the
way it's not bad in JoJo right it's I'm
just it's just like you you're reading
it or you're watching it and you're like
it is a bit like weirdly shoved in it's
it's been shoe horny it's yeah it feels
like it feels very it comes out of my
face it comes out of it he really I
remember watching the episode and I was
just like Wow have you read the Manga I
haven't read she didn't know that was
coming no no it was coming and I was
still like oh my God
sorry I'm watching JoJo part six
watching a [ __ ] span battle get
against women
racism I was like what JoJo what the
[ __ ]
it was narrated as well and the narrator
talks about it in a very weird way I
think it felt like it was very uh I
don't even know how to describe it it's
just odd it was odd yeah I was watching
it and I even know what was happening
and I was like Yep this is as weird as I
remember it being yeah this is a bit odd
it's really weird that the two portrait
the two big portrayals of racism in
anime manga that I remember one is now
like Jojo the other one is like domestic
girlfriends what what yeah because the
uh there's there's an arc there's an arc
where one of the girls uh goes to
America to uh to to uh I was a mommy or
whatever her name was it's rui oh no I'm
thinking of Randy girlfriend
uh it's uh so she goes to America to go
learn how to be a chef and be a cook and
she goes uh to America to a culinary
school and uh she the best way I can
describe it is she encounters racism and
it's not subtle all racism at all it's
very very in your face it's almost
pretty much the same level of what I saw
in Jojo and it was it just put things
into perspective of me as like you know
it's like it's really good that
there are these portrayals and Anime I
think it's good it's just also it's it
it's very jarring it's very jarring
considering what's you know the stories
I've seen told in like Western Street
domestic girlfriend yeah a domestic
girlfriend she's like this is not this
is like
it'd be like watching a Thomas the Tank
and then suddenly it's like hardcore
racism it's like whoa oh it's like we
don't we don't talk to the cars Thomas
we don't [ __ ] with those it was it was
so jarring and I I just was not prepared
for it and I wouldn't even call it like
subtle yeah
um but at least you know at least it's
happening you know at least it's
happening yeah again I don't think I'm
not trying to be like no no this
conversations can't have an anime it's
just like I think sometimes it's it
needs to be implemented a little a
little subtle a little more in a way
where it doesn't feel like there was
because there was nothing in JoJo or
even remotely about like yeah racism at
all or any of those things and then boom
they just throw it in there it's like
whoa and it only happens once yeah it
just happened once never comes up again
it's like there was yeah there's like I
mean for the characters it's a big thing
and I I like the character and I like
how they're all worked into it it just
kind of came out of nowhere
um but it was cool I I like I again I
like Jojo a lot
racism
I I like it when anime tries to go into
this stuff and tries to be more mature
yeah
um but yeah it wasn't I showed as well
wasn't it well well I still did it in a
way that was very not cool no that
wasn't cool I'm trying to think of like
yeah there's just some it's just like
okay come on let's have let's have more
characters like you know like I see I I
A lot of people are like no I don't want
any diversity in my shows I'm like yeah
dude [ __ ] it yeah let's have more
diversity and sure like if it lends to
the story well let's [ __ ] do it if
it's not jarrant to the story and you
can implement it in a way that seems
natural then hell yeah I was like shield
21 was just like dude it is a black guy
playing sports he must be amazing at
them it's like what that is not how you
introduce a character that is not that
is not how you introduce anyone it's
flat out I I think it was just the fact
that they basically gave him a
superpower and his superpower was yeah
yeah he was he was black and I was just
like what
I Shield what what are you doing it's
just like that Meme of like the the guy
with his like smiling and then his mouth
drops it's like yeah more diversity
Anatomy yeah oh I found out why this
diversity oh no
you know I feel like summer it's you
could make some really [ __ ] cool
stories with it just be be like better
with it like don't just do it don't
shoot don't shove it and don't shove it
just in a racist way in a racist way
yeah well I mean I mean it's cool you
know if we see these kinds of like
portrayals because it means like there
is some kind of conversation happening
in Japan yeah it just you know it seems
pretty cool to have that yeah yeah it's
just seeing it you obviously see that
the conversation is like not as like
far-flung as what we've had in the west
no because in Japan it's not so much
about like targeting a specific race
it's about targeting all Races yeah
essentially a lot of times people
complain that there's not enough
diversity in uh on anime and stuff I see
a lot of people like well it's for
Japanese people there you know what do
you mean what do you expect for them I
mean yes Japan is very homogeneous but
it's not like there's no diversity no
it's like pretending like other other
like ethnicities don't exist here yeah
it's just flat out wrong like yeah Joey
is a hopper like you know what I mean
like straight up just not true they
always say like it doesn't exist in
Japan or is you know that's the problem
it's like it's such a small minority
even in Japan and I think in in the eyes
of like the the Manga and Anime
Industries just like oh okay yeah we
know they exist but are they a market
that reads monger and watches anime yeah
we don't know so instead of just
pertaining to the one percent let's try
and just make the 99 happy and it's like
okay yeah you can do that if you want
but again you're gonna start running
into problems like I shielded yeah I'm
not saying just start shoving it in like
crazy to meet quotas or anything like
that because that has clearly not been a
solution anyway if the story lends well
to it let's [ __ ] do it because it
makes sense right like just like a
pattern I've seen in all of these things
that we just mentioned is that does the
anime or Manga have an America Arc you
don't need to put racism in it just
because it's like has an America you do
yeah manga artists need to understand
racism exists outside of America as well
it's not exclusive to America it's an
American exclusive
oh my God
what a great way to end trash taste
steps okay talking about races you gotta
love it hey but uh look at all these
patrons right here they don't laugh at
racism
what is that right guys I bet you don't
yeah and guys racism bad racism I just
wanted to say wow what a hot take racism
is bad guys but if you like to support
this show go over to our patreon
patreon.com trash days also follow us on
Twitter send us a memes in the subreddit
and if you hate our face listen to us on
Spotify what a great start to 2023.
we'll see you guys in the coming year
yes bye-bye
[Music]
foreign
[Music]